wealth breakthroughs is an exclusive
video series where millionaires break
their silence on their usually hidden
secrets on how to stack up great wealth
it's like eavesdropping on the private
conversations Rich folks have with each
other behind closed doors but I
partnered with the series Creator Jeff
Hayes to bring that VIP pass to you
right here today in this episode you'll
learn how to train your mind for wealth
how to 50x your Investments why $500 a
day can keep a real job away and how to
not get scammed don't miss this episode
if you're serious about your Financial
Freedom
enjoy hello and welcome to episode two
of wealth breakthroughs I'm Patrick
gentempo and I'm even more excited about
the lineup we have for this episode two
than I was for episode one we're going
to start with Dean graos author of
amongst other famous titles millionaire
success habits for my mindset to
confidence to real estate strategies
talking to Dean is like catching
lightning in a bottle he's one of the
most infectiously upbeat enthusiastic
experts I've ever spoken with when Dean
walks into a room you can feel the
energy in the room change he has laser
sharp ideas on Why without the right
mindset finding your wealth breakthrough
is next to Impossible thankfully he's
also ready to share with you exactly how
you can train your mind to make your
wealth breakthroughs the reality here's
[Music]
de a lot of anticipation for this
interview Dean thanks so much for taking
the time it's good to be here man so
you're well known uh even people in our
crew were excited that you were coming
when they heard you're coming for our
wealth breakthrough interview tell us
your story how'd you get to be doing
what you're doing yeah you know um and
first off it's good to be here with you
man and I love all you're doing for the
world seriously the world needs uh more
more of it you know access to knowledge
and information inspiration tactics you
know I'll tell my story just so everyone
watching um knows that wherever you are
I get it CU I know what it's like to be
broke and hope for more have envy that
others are getting ahead feeling like
you're being left behind trying to get
that first sale know you have more to
give the world but you don't know where
to start and then once you start you
don't know how to get the wheels
spinning right but I know what it's like
to get to 100 Grand a year and be like
oh my God I made it but then I realize
that wasn't it and get to 100 Grand a
month and 100 Grand a week 100 Grand a
day and 100 Grand by 10 in the morning
so I've been at every one of those
pieces and it failed miserably in
between sleepless nights you know an
ulcer and St because you're so stressed
but over time your knowledge your
failures the things you uh go after they
go from knowledge to wisdom and when I
look back now I realize that was my
journey and I'm so blessed that wouldn't
change one bit of it and when people say
is it worth it it's like hell yes what's
the opposite of going for it being at
the end of your life and and I know you
asked me about my story I just want to
back up and give you some of the things
that that drive me is I always think of
at the end of my life if you're sitting
with your maker God whoever you believe
in you're sitting next to him and you
say well you know I and he asked you how
your life was and you go you know I was
going to go for it but you know my wife
wasn't always on my side or I lived in
the wrong area or my husband you know he
had his career I didn't want to disturb
him in any way or I didn't have the
intelligence or I I wasn't born with
money I believe our maker would be like
oh my God another one like I made you
human I put you on Earth I give you
Limitless potential and I think about
that all the time um and that's why I
think doesn't matter where you are we
heard that a million times it only
matters if you can gain the capabilities
and you have the stamina to keep going
so what I hope and the reason I flew up
here to be with you and want to do this
interview is I hope at the end of this
even if just one person person gets the
inspiration to go or one person gets a
tactic that we share that's enough right
take what serves you from this interview
throw the rest away you know so I I'll
go back to my story here but so let me
ask you a quick question before you do
that do you think you've learned more
from your failures or your successes
yeah hands down from my failures hands
down so it's tuition B and you don't
like it like like when people say I
sometimes people say embrace your
failures failing sucks it's the worst
feeling in the world when you're in the
middle of it you're not going thank you
God I was appreciate I was looking
forward to this next failure but but
what you realize especially looking back
now and we've been in this game for so
long as an entrepreneur and and in the
in the self-education industry it's my
next level of life always lived on the
other side of my biggest failure or my
biggest fear right right the the fear
that you ignore that's the one that you
need to freaking tackle that's the
mountain you have to climb or you're
going to stay where you are and and we
all know 5 years goes by like this right
it reminds me of the Joseph Campbell
quote uh in the cave you fear most is
the knowledge you seek yeah yeah exactly
uh so um in your own story then you tell
us a little bit about the Milestones
yeah so I'll just pop through the
Milestone so um in high school if I go
all the way back to high school wasn't a
great student had dyslexia really just
didn't want to be a part of school at
all by 11th grade I was out of school by
you know 11:00 in the morning I did gym
math and English and I think I was out
maybe Ceramics maybe ceramic class um
because I had dyslexia and because I
felt inferior being in school I just was
going to go to work right but I I guess
if I if I go back you don't realize this
stuff when you're in it it's retrospect
it's it's hindsight it's looking
backwards is what I realized at a really
young age Patrick is that both my
parents worked really hard my parents
were married nine times between them I
watched them move all over so they were
struggling to be happy they were
struggling financially I lived in a
trailer park until we got evicted from
it and my mom worked three jobs to make
90 bucks a week my dad worked in a
collision shop all day all night to come
home you know dirty hands and and paint
fumes give him a headache but he had to
do it and what I realized at a young age
I don't know when it was is that I hard
work had nothing to do with success and
again it wasn't like an epiphany and
like I'm going to go out and find
mentors but that's how it led it's like
I love my dad I love my mom but they're
stressed all the freaking time they
never have any money and they're not
really that happy and they were looking
for a relationship to make them happy
now that I look back and that wasn't
doing it either because they weren't
internally happy but they couldn't find
time to work on them because they had to
worry about paying the bills and it was
a really like this Epiphany at a young
age again I said it wasn't like the sky
parted but I realized hard work didn't
do it and then I realized if you could
get money out of the
way like money solves problems it
doesn't if somebody says money doesn't
buy happiness that's not they haven't
given enough money away they haven't
given enough meals away they haven't
helped somebody like money solves
problems and I realized that at a young
age and I went after it like I was just
hungry for it um and if I look back back
and I always tell everybody find a
burning desire we all need that and
you've heard it a million times but mine
was my mom she worked three jobs she'd
come home at night literally her hands
hurt she got arthritis young her leg
legs would hurt her back would hurt cuz
she was cleaning houses and sweeping
floors and cutting hair and I just
remember saying I don't care what it
takes I'm going to make money and retire
my mom right and that was the that was
the first lesson I learned on having a
compelling future it's like I'm retiring
my mom which I I did in my 20s but so I
realized that didn't work I found some
older people in my town that seemed that
my dad didn't even like he's a small
town of 5,000 People Patrick and you
know it's like small town half the town
three4 of town was Italian Catholic
everybody's rumors on the on the
weekends at church like it was just a
fun little town and my dad wasn't the
happiest with these guys but I came
friends with a couple guys 6070 one guy
was almost 80 years old and they just
had different habits they they treated
people differently they they felt like
they just had a different sense of Peace
but they were the wealthiest people in
town also happy also good parents good
husbands or good like was I was like I
want to do more of what they do and less
of what my parents do not disrespectful
and it took me down a path um when I was
17 years old I uh I had a firewood
business by 18 I was fixing wck cars I'd
fix them up and sell them by 19 I bought
my first house with no money down fixed
it up sold it by 20 I had 22 Apartments
I had a collision shop by 22 collision
shop by 24 I had tow truck company Auto
Sales company uh real estate company I
was I had apartment then I started
buying raw land subdividing and then
building houses um how did you how did
you start getting in cuz these are not
related things that you're talking you
know real estate and and Tow shops you
they're not in the same category of
business was it just circumstances that
led you in those directions I think so
if I look back the the three guys that I
told you about in my town were all in
real estate my dad was in a collision
shop so collision shop got me there I
wanted to go to Real Estate cuz I just
said wealthy people do real estate I'm
going to do that and Desperation and
stupidity are a are a magical
combination and you could think back in
your own life right when people said oh
you can't buy real estate with no money
down I was stupid and I even enough to
go yeah I think other people do it I saw
a guy on TV doing it right um and being
desperate to get away from a painful
situation both of those were such
drivers that I got in my first deal and
so I want to back up a little bit and I
just want to put myself out there to
really understand something at 22 years
old I was working with my dad in his
collision shop he made me a 25% partner
all my friends had maybe 21 maybe 20 um
all my friends had gone off to college
one was in Miami University Dancing on
tables having a blast my friends are all
over hitting me up like dude come down
and visit and I'm like at least my dad
named his collision shop Paul and Dean
Autobody and I got 25% he probably made
50 Grand a year I was probably making 12
Grand a year but I owned a piece of this
at least I wasn't the complete you know
not go to college loser and I knew there
was more me and my dad fought a lot we
did because he had his old ways and I
thought I had Visionary ways and he
thought I was D young and dumb and I
thought he was old and stuck in his ways
right but my dad long story short he's
the youngest at 12 and got beat as a y
young kid and never worked on that
bipolar up and down he went through his
fourth divorce and gave up on life
closed the collision shop checked
himself in someplace and they wouldn't
let him out because then he got really
mad and he just went away and he said
I'm letting it all go go work at a
factory you're done so imagine no matter
what age you are at least I had that
hope so now I'm using a credit card to
pay my dad's mortgage so he doesn't lose
his house while he's in someplace that
they won't let him out I moved all the
stuff out of my dad's collision shop I
find this Barn 100-year-old barn on the
property where I was living I put a wood
stove in it I put a compressor in it I
put the tools in it and I'm working on
people in friends Cars changing brakes
doing Motor jobs changing oil painting
and I'm just like and this is the part
where I wanted to get into and it's the
two voices I'm still fighting to this
day inside of me the voice that said see
you're not that smart you probably
should have went to college your friends
are smart you didn't come from money
your parents don't have money this is
where you belong you're going to make
500 800 bucks a week the rest of your
life I had that voice saying we're
screwed and wanting to feel depressed
but I was lucky enough to also have this
other voice that would say screw that I
don't care what everybody else does I
don't care how much I don't care I don't
have a college Dee in fact because I
don't have a college degree because I
have dyslexia because people think I
can't because I'm an underdog watch
everybody I mean even in 12th grade my
little slogan under my name was you
don't hear me now but someday you'll
hear me roar something like that was my
quote so I had these two voices and some
days the shitty voice would win for lack
of a better telling me I can't and I and
I'd be depressed and think I couldn't
but most days this one was just a little
bit stronger and it was like a it was
like a almost a tie score it was like
2122 the better voice would win so now
I'm in this collision shop working on
one car at a time half of me part of me
thinks this is pathetic my friends I'm
embarrassed for them to come home now
cuz now I got envy that they all figured
it out and I'm stuck um my dad comes
home and he's in a terrible space I get
in the first fist fight of my life with
my Dad we stopped talking because he was
just really in a depressed mode and then
one day and this is the part I want to
tell you one day I just said if I don't
make a change like it was probably a low
moment I'm going to be my dad and just
again if my dad saw this he knows the
way I feel I said I'm going to be my dad
I'm going to be another generation of
broke rosis who work their asses off die
with you know their hands dirty they
have strong man hands but nothing not a
dollar I'm not going to be that guy and
I went down and again if it was
desperate whatever drove me I went to
the woman who owned the collision shop
building that my dad moved out of and I
said hey I'm not my dad I love my dad
and I don't have any money but I have I
have a burning desire and I knew if you
let me back in that collision shop I'll
pay you more rent than anybody else but
I have no money to give you I went to
her house a couple Sundays in a row she
gave me a hug and she said go for it I
still remember Mary lepry sweetest lady
I could cry thinking about her like she
had no reason I got goosebumps no reason
to do that for me and she did it and uh
I named it Dean Collision Center and I
just went after it with pure
desperations like I still play Patrick I
still play like I'm 10 points down in
everything I approach like I don't take
anything for granted I don't expect
someone's going to give me money I don't
expect that the the government is going
to help it or I'm going to get the loan
at the bank or the deal is going to go
through or the partner I don't just I
just play like I'm 10 points down I go
in that collision shop I start working
and then I built up that collision shop
I realized little things from my older
friends that giving reciproc overd
delivering being transparent being
authentic I closed Enterprise ran a car
which this tiny little shop with this
young kid I get this big account which
meant two CH two or three tow trucks and
a you know million dollar year account
and I got I started going there and then
houses and real estate and all those
things I showed you I told you and then
uh and I'll go really quick so we can
get to some deeper stuff but then in
about I was about 25 26 years old I
bought Tony Robbins course and it was
the first time I was ever introduced to
personal growth or self-education like
it was just it was I didn't read books
back then I was just I was just grinding
it out I didn't realize like I had an
extra 4,000 pounds on my back the way I
would stress the way I would worry I I
would never practice gratitude or never
have a morning like nothing I would just
think that stuff was fofu until I saw
Tony one night and I just believed
everything he said on this infomercial I
bought it I got those capabilities and
everything shifted I mean the way I
thought shifted the way I practiced
gratitude shifted not overnight I wasn't
like oh this is perfect
but it shifted me and it t it introduced
me to Wayne Dyer and Dale Carnegie and
Jim rone and Earl Nightingale and eart
toi and then all of a sudden I'm like oh
my God why didn't somebody when I was
young my guidance counselor said you're
not going to school o you could work
with your dad or at the local Factory no
one said you can go down the middle Road
and read books get a mentor work for
someone for free go to a workshop go to
a mastermind this that world like it
blew my mind that that world existed and
I went head first in it within 2 years
years in 1998 I filmed my first
infomercial I Rel released my first uh
course on helping people do what I did
my first one was how to make money with
cars and uh I went on TV in 1998 and I
had a 20-year run uh since then my
Brands and my companies have done over a
billion dollars and I've been able to
touch the lives of millions of people
around the world and and now we're on
another Journey doing some great stuff
in fact I'm partners with Tony now so
the world's a crazy place I hope that
wasn't too long that was actually
perfect and the lessons I think are in
the story in so many ways
one of the things that's really
interesting cuz people say okay well
Dean was um picked the right horse you
know he got into real estate and that's
what did it but no there's something
more fundamental than that because of
the success of the shop right saying you
closed I had a kick-ass firewood
business in high school yeah you know so
so there's there's a there's a more
foundational element saying okay this is
the key to success are having a wealth
breakthrough now you focus your
attention in firewood would you know
auto mechanics and towing uh real estate
whatever it might be and obviously
there's arguments to be made on the
practicality of what you know uh
industry you'll get in but ultimately
you're going to succeed no matter where
you go would you agree with that yeah
and and here's here's what I'd say in my
20s if someone said if you have a
foundation for Success you anchor in
success principles so I wrote
millionaire success habits it's one of
the best selling books last couple years
cuz I wanted to share these but if you
told me in my 20s Dean or Patrick if we
were sitting together in our 20s and
someone said if you anchor in a
foundation for Success you guys could do
whatever you want i' be like this guy's
drunk get him on your face give me the
tool like you just want the thing should
I do Shopify should I start my own
business should I get into real estate
should I should I do seminars should I
do events should I be a doctor a chiropr
like we all think it's the thing it's
never the thing it's never the thing and
I think maybe you could say the same
thing as I I would bet to say I thought
mindset was 10% in my 20s then 30% in my
30s and now in my 50s it's 95% because
you can give somebody a business on how
to sell $20 bills for 10 bucks and it'll
come back to you a month Ando you know
what nobody thinks this is true doesn't
work where I live nobody really likes
$20 bills I don't have time for it my
husband doesn't believe in me it's like
oh my God right so um I'd love to chat
about if you want some of the things I
believe are the core pieces to
sustainable success or I'll go down any
road you want yeah so I I definitely
want to talk about that so A couple of
things uh first is and and what I relate
to um is that I had my daughter's
dyslexic also so we had to pull her out
of school and homeschooler because that
environment just wasn't adapted to her
CU otherwise you end up you know uh she
did at points in time hitting herself in
the head saying I'm stupid I did all the
time and you lose your confidence
without confidence you do nothing
exactly and then the head space starts
to degenerate and I think she gets at me
cuz you know I I I think I'm mildly
dyslexic but they didn't have they
didn't really diagnose that back when I
was in high school so was there I
understand those struggles and uh
there's a sense of identity that comes
along with this so two things I have you
know an interest in number one it's
education because one of the things you
said is wait a minute I was in school my
friends went to college I you know I was
like not even making in high school and
it was very debilitating for me it was
but then all of a sudden a World opened
up like you know the theas part and then
all a sudden you see my God there's an
entire line of education for me that can
lead me to places that my other even my
friends couldn't get to with the
education track they were taking so
maybe in in a in a brief statement you
can talk about what you think about
education right now and and cuz most
people who are watching this you know
the viewer is looking they're in that
education system or went through it and
that's probably a thing that has to be
corrected of course corre I mean this is
a topic for me that that's like so near
and dear to my heart because not only
was it personal I just watched I mean
there's a whole generation of
Millennials right now with angst with
debt who are getting houses 8 years
later because of their college debt and
don't know what to do with their life
life the the education system just
didn't keep up with times it didn't
evolve as fast as the world has evolved
and it's been letting people down for a
long time and now the world is realizing
it I just it's why I'm such an advocate
of it I'm sure you are too because
self-education and that's the industry
we talk about saved my life it saved my
partner Tony robbin's life probably
saved you if I didn't learn from other
people if I didn't know that existed and
the reason I want to be such an advocate
and the reason I love doing an interview
like this is you know how many people
right now are listening or watching
and they don't know what to do with
their life because they were only told
one path right they were only if if if
general knowledge Napoleon Hill wrote in
1937 general knowledge no matter how
wide how vast will never lead to
economic growth or money in your life
the only thing that does is specialized
knowledge and that's how we learn uh
that's how what self-education does it
allows you to gain specialized Knowledge
from somebody who's already done it if I
want to know what you do I just want to
spend a weekend with you right I don't
want to go to school for four years and
and and I'll give a prime example my
daughter's here she came with my wife
she's probably going be like oh cringey
he's talking about me no cuz she's 13
now I'm just kidding but we look off
camera and look at her yeah but here's
the thing here's what I told her because
this is personal it's in my house my my
firstborn L to death I tell her let's
just say she's really great with art and
fashion if she wanted to be an interior
designer and this is the story I've told
her I hope she doesn't go to college I
most parents are like try to get your
kids in college I hope she doesn't go
she wants to go one year for fun fine go
goof off and then we'll get back to life
but I said here's the thing you can go
to school for 4 years we can pay for
that that's fine then you can get out
and get a business and maybe an art
degree and then you go work for somebody
for four or five years and see how that
works and maybe five 10 12 years later
you start your own business and that's
the path so many take and most people
never start their own thing they get
sucked into the mediocrity they get the
mortgage the car payment and they got
the bills and they stay in the job and
they never reach into themselves and
find another level right I said or Bri
we could search and find the top five uh
interior designers in America we we'll
look all over TR to find the top five
and together we're going to craft the
best letter in the world and say that
you're going to go work for her or him
for a year for free and you'll be the
best employee they ever had in their
life I said between if we send it to
five we're going to get one then we go
out if you feel comfortable with them
you work for free and you be the best
employee they've ever had but the entire
time you are extracting every bit of
knowledge you get them to condense their
decade or two into a year and extract it
when you're done and you come home you
could start off where they left off
that's selfed education and no one ever
explained it that simple get a mentor
find somebody get in a mastermind read
books books are filled with treasure
maps you just I mean every think about
this Patrick with all the books we've
read the people we've met pretty much
every answer to every question I've ever
had I can find between a person I know a
book a course or a workshop or a
mastermind right but most people don't
even know that it seems Seems foreign to
them most people think I want to make
more money let me go back and get my
masters do you know right now if you go
back and get your Masters on average in
America it's only about a $6,200 a year
raise so you go back spend two years
spend the money it just doesn't work so
self-education saved my life and it's
absolutely I just got done writing a
book I just launched it called the
underdog Advantage there's a whole
chapter in there that said Underdog
self-educate CU in so many cases when
you're an underdog you don't have
privilege around you you can't go to the
best school you can't ask your parents
they think you're insane your friends
think you're an idiot they tell you to
stop dreaming so what do underdogs do in
most cases if you look back from George
Washington or Abraham Lincoln or anybody
from Michael Jordan to LeBron James if
you're a sports fan if you look at any
of those underdogs what did they do they
self-educated they read the books they
practiced in their room they got a coach
like they self-educated so um yeah I
think one of the biggest secrets to to
wealth and ongoing wealth and
sustainable wealth is you must continue
to learn and who you learn from is so
important you want to learn from this is
going to sound terrible but you want to
learn from a teacher a professional
teacher in a classroom who's never done
it or do you want to find
nonprofessional teacher who's actually
doing it had success and willing to
share it it's an obvious choice right so
there's a thing that I think is
correlates with this um is that you have
a sense of identity when you're that kid
in high school getting ready to come out
starting your business Etc and over time
you have your experiences and you grow
and like you said you know you can go
from 100 Grand a year to 100 Grand by 10
a.m. you know that that can happen y has
your identity changed over time your
sense of self and how you perceive
yourself or do you think it's pretty
much the same I think I probably had
moments where it changed but right now
I'm I'm back to who I was just smarter
wiser and um not as much as a fool make
less dumb decisions right time allows
you to figure that stuff out right you
hit your thumb with the hammer enough
you know that that hurts I should stop
hitting myself with it but I think for
me I I actually um I like to be again
this is one of my traits that I think is
everyone should hear but I like to be
underestimated I like to I like to
really practice not practice being
humble like it's a practice like I want
to be humble I want to always remember
because you know as much as as well as
we've done you could lose it overnight
right um so I never want to rely on that
but of course it's a part of my identity
now that I get to you know impact
people's lives I have money I don't
worry about money anymore I can take
care of my family I pay I retired my
parents many many years ago I can
provide for my kids and do all those
things but um I think the more
especially in today's world and I'm
going to digress a little bit here
Patrick but I think people always ask me
how are you going so good at sales um
and I think that's my unique ability
marketing and sales I and I create great
products once I get in their hands but
um if you look at what I do I'm
extremely authentic with my sales
whether that's on TV online whatever I
do and I think that's I think that's
something we need to take into
consideration in today's world um I
think leaning into your authenticity
leaning into your weaknesses being
exposed being vulnerable vable to your
weakness but but letting the world
people let the world see your strengths
I think that's what we want
subconsciously more than ever people
always ask what's the X Factor I think
I'm I just want to continue to find
really who I am and then let the world
know more of who I am um and work a lot
on my strengths and ignore my weaknesses
interesting concept or you know that
you're bringing out is strengths versus
weaknesses and uh so you're what I'm
inferring at least I think from what you
just said is that what you do is you
build success based on strength you
don't try to get your weaknesses up is
that is that the way you see it 100%
like so your daughter has dyslexia do
you know Ned Hollowell yes very well
yeah so Ned's a great guy right add
specialist um we had a business together
oh yeah okay focuses on dyslexia and add
and and things that make uh kids lose
their confidence right so I talking to
him one day and I feel like I probably
had add as a kid definitely dyslexia
said a lot of times they go together so
I said to them how do you cure so many
kids why is Oprah call you the number
one add or just you know specialist on
the planet and he said something really
really simple he said when you see a kid
in class and he's trying to sit down and
and read and he can't read and he's
tapping his foot and the teacher said
you stay there and read until you're
done and all of a sudden he called him
Johnny all of a sudden Johnny can't read
and Johnny gets up and starts running
around not only Hees have ADD he's got
ADHD he's hyper right and then they
medicate and they push and all that does
is knock that confidence down more and
more and pull that kid and go he goes
inside and then there's no way to get to
him he said said what most people don't
realize the cure for add the cure for
dyslexia is not to point out the kids'
weaknesses what I do is I get with the
teachers I get with his family and I get
with his siblings and I say what's
Johnny good at Johnny's good at math
he's just kind of bad at everything else
okay we're going to focus on math and
we're going to make Johnny so good at
math that we're g to get his confidence
back because he's going to get A's in
math he's going to feel good about
himself and guess what when Johnny gets
A's in math and people start patting him
on the back and as confidence goes up
we're going to fast forward and he's
going to be sitting down reading that
book like I get goosebumps talking about
it because it's so simple in this world
I remember I remember Mrs Thompson like
it was yesterday calling me stupid just
sound it out I'm like I'm trying to
sound it out I can't and I'd go home and
cry in seventh grade and I'd feel really
bad about myself not blaming Miss
Thompson that's probably how she was
brought up the whole point is those
little nuances we need to do that for
ourselves cuz no one's going to say let
me identify what you're good at Patrick
Let's help you we got to look inside and
go stop looking at the stuff I'm weak at
stop saying I didn't I'm not far enough
ahead in my life I should have done more
I missed that opportunity all those
things we could say that forever but it
serves us nothing it Ser it serves no
bigger purpose that's right because at
the end of the day kind of leading back
and forth I believe we should ignore our
weaknesses I still suck at reading and
I'm a multiple New York Times
bestselling author I just released my
sixth book I can't even write a sentence
without 14 words being lit up and I
can't even Word Check can't even fix
them sometimes they're so far off and I
just put like amazing in there instead
of some elaborate word right so we have
to ignore our weaknesses I believe and
all of me it's what help me and then
find out what we're good at and get so
good that they cover all the rest and
someday if it's not now you pay someone
to do all the things you're weak at and
you stay in that core competency and
that unique B unique ability and I think
there's a bigger by product Patrick and
and you said something really cool and
and I'm I'm I wouldn't have any doubts
with you about pulling your daughter out
because nothing happens in life without
confidence that's right if you think of
the people we know that their confidence
is just a little bit they play small
their entire life you don't close the
deal you don't start the company you
don't get the girl you don't get the guy
you don't get the partner to give you
the money the bank doesn't give you the
money you know people when your
confidence is down even 5% it doesn't
work and here's something if this is if
nothing else can shock you into not
working on your weaknesses how do you
feel when you work on your weaknesses
incompetent right if you said to your
daughter right she's having a good day
and you tell your daughter right now if
she was here and you sit her down and
say hey here's a book can you read these
20 pages to my friend Dean how would you
make her feel yeah if you did it to me
I'm I'm literally reading my book my six
book I'm reading it I'm a month in dude
I still can't read my brain goes faster
my eyes and my brain goes faster like I
know what's coming next and I skip and I
skip and then I mess up the words right
if you did that to me I would feel
really I would lose my confidence and
when you lose your confidence here am I
supposed to go down the street and do
good on video or go down and close the
deal or or make a deal on the house or
whatever business you're in you don't so
to go along with that work on your
strengths and ignore your weaknesses is
one of the biggest things for success is
protecting your confidence and if
watching the news robs your confidence
don't watch it if reading out loud dings
your confidence don't do it like I tell
I tell my kids all the time like a
teacher wants you to read in front of
the class and you don't want you don't
don't just say no just say no like if
you were in my if you worked with me and
you're on my team and you said hey I'd
be really embarrassed to read in front
of me I wouldn't go oh then I think I'm
on a fire like then don't read what are
you good at oh I like doing this okay
bring in your artwork or do like I would
never do that and that's not the real
world and that's what we miss but
someone did that to her teacher or his
teacher and they just think that's let's
make them get great work on your
weaknesses to get stronger it's like no
then you then you end up with a bunch of
weaknesses that are okay rather than
polishing this diamond that lives inside
of all of us you know what's brilliant
in that example or that metaphor is um
is the fact that you know everybody and
well maybe let me see if you have the
premise before I I make the statement is
it a premise that you hold that
everybody has some genius in them
everyone they just okay so there's
nobody so somebody out there saying well
no I'm not really good at anything
that's a fallacy right it's
fallacy yeah yeah so that everybody has
some genius and of course if they're
working in their genius or expressing it
like my daughter's a genius songwriter
and a singer so that's that's that's we
and that's her life that's her career
that you you can't stop her from wanting
to sing right and when she's singing her
like as you talked about confidence like
trying to get up and read in front of a
room or or you know what her experience
was horrible I was worried I'm speaking
in front of 3,000 people there's a band
on stage so that we they invite us to
come do a song with him and I'm like I
want to bring her out on the stage get
her used to it 3,000 people you know no
problem walked right out had all the
comp she was in her unique ability right
she was in her core competency exactly
so it it shows up everywhere so to me
what's what's uh fascinating and what
speaks to you know what you're talking
about as an example is that it becomes
critical then to find out what is that
unique ability what is that genius that
you have and uncovering that I'll never
forget when I was sitting with Hollowell
once in his office and we're working on
this business and he's talking about add
and I finally looked up at him at one
point I said Ned you know based on what
you're describing I think I might be add
he goes you're totally ad so you didn't
know and and he said something so
profound that was so true for me he said
you know somebody with ADD could spend
10 years trying to turn a weakness into
a strength they just keep and I'm
looking at myself saying that was
probably most of the pain in my life
trying to get good at things that were
weaknesses for me and that Set Me Free
in a big way and the reason you know
what the reason you and I are talking
about so many different conversations
it's been too long since we've been
together I have so many things I want to
share so I love this and I hope I hope
we're not going into too many different
directions but I have to tell you so
just talking on this because I really
want to Anchor this in because there's a
lot of people watching or listening
right now that have been carrying around
a weakness since they were in school
they were told they were sloppy they
were unintelligent they couldn't read
they weren't fast enough they were lazy
they were a procrastinator and you carry
that and you it's like 4,000 lb you got
to push off right so I'm doing a small
Mastermind maybe 10 years ago 10 people
in the room and I'm going around the
room and saying what's the biggest thing
holding your back why haven't you had a
breakthrough uh it's this it's this and
I get to this guy Tom I remember Tom
probably 68 years old and this was in
real estate and uh Tom had already done
four deals at the time probably made 15
grand a deal whatever let's just say
he's at $60,000 in profit amazing he
retired was sick of being retired he
wanted to do it so I get around to Tom
and he says I said why aren't you going
faster Tom why aren't you go to the next
level he's like you know what I'm not
doing another deal until I get organized
he's like I'm the sloppiest person the
world I could clean my car and it's a
disaster I go home my home office and
there's bills stacked all over he's like
I'm a mess I need to go to this was 10
years I need to go to Office Max I need
to get a filing cabinet I need to label
everything and I need to start a system
and a process and I said Tom how old are
you he said 68 I said can I be honest
with you you're going to be a slob till
the day you die and who gives a and
he looked at me like I was being rude at
first and I said Tom listen to me
there's a bunch of people in this room
younger than you they haven't done four
deals yet you did four deals why do you
think you did those deals he goes I kind
of got a knack of hitting around to find
these deals he said well wait a minute
what do you mean and he explained I said
let me just ask you do you think it's
worth your time at 68 years old to try
to keep your car clean or your office
clean what if you just did one extra
deal a year you found that sniffing
around method that you have what if you
did one extra deal a year and you got
better at that and you find two I said
how's it feel when you get made that
money how's it feel when you sold the
house he goes oh everybody said I
couldn't it felt amazing was lit up then
I talk him about being organized and i'
he'd literally like shrink shoulders
would shrink face would go he looked 10
years difference in age when he talked
about doing the thing he was good at or
doing the thing he wasn't and I said Tom
what if you just had a different point
what if I said did teachers tell you
that he goes yeah he goes truthfully my
wife tells me that all the time I he
said great lady she just tells me all
the time I said what if you just
admitted you were a slop what if you got
amazing at what you're already good at
you did one extra deal a year and you
paid someone to clean your house clean
your car and keep you organized and he
started to cry and he's like why didn't
anybody ever tell me this and like I I
like I went over and hugged him because
he was crying because you know why he
wasn't crying not because of what I said
he was crying because he held on that he
was inferior because he was a slob since
he was a little kid his mom yelling at
him to clean his room his wife getting
on him probably at work getting on him
this was an amazing man who had a
weakness who gives a I'm never
going to get good at spelling ever ever
in the history of the world he's never
going to be clean and here's the cool
part he called me he got got a hold of
our office got my email sent me this
long email about 6 months later went
home and just told his wife the whole
thing she felt so bad that she was on
him like that she said why don't we make
a deal she quit being a teacher and she
went partners with him and kept him
organized because she was an organized
teacher and he goes she does the
organization I do the deals and he was
on fire and not that I mean I was just
glad he was there in that room cuz he
would have held that to the day died
that's right right and that's
interesting cuz these are the pieces of
identity thing that you might hold on I
suck because I can't X and then as a
result it's like you know it inhibits I
mean you know how can you try to express
fully so then if we talk about uh well
let me ask this first yeah yeah what's
your definition of success oh man that's
probably changed all through the years
and and that's interesting because you
saw it probably some way before and
you're seeing it differently now so
maybe you can speak at at 24 years old
when I finally started making a little
money success was that on a Thursday I
could jump on a plane fly to Miami go to
a club get bottle service and dance on a
table till 3:00 in the morning that is
so far I I would die if I did that today
right but that I thought I was
successful I was the broke kid from a
small town now I'm in Miami it's amazing
the energy is good I'm alive like that
was success it was also taking care of
my mom there was you know I'm
exaggerating not really but I was there
was other things that was successful I
believe success identifying what success
means and it was a really great question
it's one of the most important things I
just did a New Year's Day training I
started with that I said two things I
think are the most important questions
to start what's success mean to you and
who do you want to become right and my
my buddy Tony Robins when I was 48
looked at me and he said who do you want
to become in your 50s and I never had
nobody all these time all this time in
this space no one had ever asked me who
I want to become I thought about what I
wanted to accomplish who I wanted to
kind of how I want to evolve but who do
I want to become what kind of and I
started thinking what kind of man do I
want to be what kind of father do I want
to be in my 50s what kind of husband do
I want to be a you know I'm going to be
a father again like who do I want to be
and when I started crafting that it
helped me align what success really
means to me so at this phase of My Life
um success means to me that my kids are
with me exactly half the time so success
to me at 3:00 when they come out of
school my trucks park there to pick them
up no matter what or my car is parked
there there's not a billion dollar deal
that could stop me from picking up my
kids there's not a billion dollar deal
that could take me away not having them
with me and being there with them and
being present and playing life and games
and doing fun stuff and you know they're
not going to be here forever also being
a better version of me to be a better
husband like that's that's success to me
having a great team my office I got 60
70 people their amazing team in the
world and making an impact on the world
that's where I'm at and and pretty much
if it falls outside of that I'm not
really interested I'm not like I don't
go to fancy parties I don't do the cool
stuff anymore I I love coming home like
so but it doesn't mean that that's for
everybody success means to me that I'm
in control of my time how I'm as a
father as a a husband as a leader and do
an impact I don't want anybody telling
me what to do and when I even think that
I could lose that I would chew through
your fireplace right but I continue to
to create what success means like a
beacon of light right this is this is
one thing I'll share with everybody what
everybody does wrong you can ask
somebody what success means they tell
you and they don't think about it for
another three months when I think about
success means to me no one's going to
take away the Father the husband the
leader and the impact I'm going to make
no one's going to take away that from me
but I need to look at it every day
Patrick so when I get up and I still
fight people say you got enough money
you could quit forever I still fight
like I'm broke I still fight like the
underdog I still fight like I'm 10 why
do you think that is why are you still
fighting like that because I don't ever
like I always I know what success means
to me and I it's like that I was talking
about like a beacon of light like I
model it but then I always push it out
like 20 ft from me I never keep it right
close to me and you enjoy that I do so
you like the energy the energy being
you'd rather be 10 points down and 10
points ahead I do I I love that that's
just for me but I identifi that and I do
that because like right now I want to
help fix along with my partner Tony look
at you're on a mission look at what
you're doing with your documentaries
it's amazing what you're doing with my
partner Tony we want to help provide a
an alternative to the current education
system we want to make self-education
the new Norm 10 years somebody goes you
went to college oh I'm sorry oh you got
self-educated okay come in the door like
that's what our goal is so when I wake
up in the morning and I think about that
dude I'm fighting like I'm broke I'm
fighting like I'm living in the trailer
again like I am like like I'm at the
office
right now before the team and after the
team right now um because of that so um
to me it say that you know that you
maintain purpose and the purpose is that
fuel that keeps driving you to to do
what you're doing you know one of the
things that comes to mind as you're
explaining success in in the giving it
the characterization that you are uh in
a previous series we interviewed Roger
Hamilton if you know Roger and I asked
the question how do you define wealth
and uh he said wealth is what you have
left after all your money is gone
and I thought that was a great that a
really good definition I'm think about
that forever yeah it's it's just like
and and to me that's what it sounded
like saying hey you know all the money
were gone my wealth are all these things
that I have in place which includes your
your intellectual Capital to go recreate
of course and and the thing I'll say
though Patrick is I'm not going to poo
poo on wealth like here's the thing I
know my dad is a good man Underneath It
All my mom's an amazing lady right if I
look at them the closest people in my
life other than my family that's here
with me now um but money was always an
issue with them so when money is an
issue you don't have time to figure out
how to eat vegan or or plant-based or
get a personal chef or get a personal uh
trainer to get you in better shape when
you don't have money you don't have the
opportunity to go to a Tony Robbins rent
or or go on a 90day binge and reading a
book every 10 days and work on your
inner peace and get rid of the Demons
you have from your parents or being
molested or or being taken advantage of
or being cheated on like all those
things my neither one of my parents ever
had a moment and I'm not making excuses
for them they just didn't have a moment
to work on themselves cuz they're always
working to make just enough money to pay
the bills yeah right you're in survival
so you're in survival mode and and who
could blame them so what I say is when
when people say money can't buy happen
it's like BS like I believe if you build
a core for success and that's start you
have to have the mindset and the
foundation and the habits without that
you're going to be spitting your wheels
and you'll dabble and everything then
bring in the right capabilities whether
that's a Shopify real estate in the
self-education whatever it is a million
different things being a chiropractor
being a doctor you have that Foundation
they're the people who win look at the
people successful in your life they have
a mindset that gets them over the
obstacles plug in anything they'll be
successful right if you plug in that
success happens right so for me if you
can sacrifice a year or three or five
because those years are going to go by
anyway that's right and you can build
some wealth in your life for me when
when I got money out of the way it's
when I started to look internally and
and I'll tell you when when money wasn't
when I wasn't running to chase the money
to have freedom when that stopped it was
a weird time in my life I don't know if
you ever felt that when there was no
more like oh I'm here I have the
house I have the money there's no bill
collectors I'm not going broke I it was
like a weird time but that was the time
I went inside that's the time I started
getting therapy on a deep level reading
books obsessively reading books that
healed my soul and my past wounds and
saw what I messed up in last
relationships and said why did I make
why did I do that and how I could be a
better man better father than my father
was and I became a better person because
I got to work on me not my poor parents
trying to pay the bills yeah you're
bringing up a really interesting point
about saying hey you know what happens
when suddenly that pressure's off and
you've lived in it for so long yeah um
you know my wife who is also my muse
taught me that we get addicted to the
hormones of stress there was literally
for me there was literally a withdrawal
it's like saying wait a minute um like
uh there's
big things going on right now but um
it's it's all handled and I'm like um I
didn't know how to be comfortable
without the stress and the pressure I've
been there it's like it was like a
withdrawal process and you know
mindfulness practices are are the way to
transcend that which is what it took for
me yeah really but you had to get to
that point to work on mindfulness
practices and and and that's the point
you're making I mean at 27 I don't know
what you're doing at 27 but if someone
said hey let's get you some mindfulness
practices like I'm going to go grab a
cocktail and I'll be just fine right you
know what I mean and those are the
stages of you know kind of the
trajectory of the Arc of of of life
because you're exactly right at 27 it
was not you know that no I I was working
seven days a week night and day uh you
know as an entrepreneur and loving every
minute of it and I didn't want to stop
to think about things I I wanted to do I
was in exactly if you don't stop you
don't think you're good right you're
golden yeah you don't have to pay
attention to any of these things so this
is to me completely fascinating um and
overall I mean when you look at embedded
in all the things that you described um
you know what success takes what um how
people can self-identify with weaknesses
and suddenly it starts to take them down
the importance of confidence I mean all
these things it's all gold I mean it's
really is the gold here's one thing and
maybe sort of a final thought as people
are watching this I observe many times
people who have struggled for years I've
worked with people who've been
struggling for years as entrepreneurs
and they they're stay just just in
survival mode I mean they're paying the
bill but it's stressful they're not
breaking through and they're looking for
a wealth breakthrough and so often I
found that they're literally just one or
two clicks away yeah they're on the one
yard line they don't even realize it
they don't even realize it so is that
your experience also that many times
people they've been putting in the the
years they they've been studying as
you're saying it can you think of 10
people you know at least 10 friends you
have at least five women five men you
can think of right now that are in the
game they know the some of the same
people we know
but they never can get past that
threshold and I I would say you know
what some of the things um a good friend
of mine Randy gar I don't know if you
know I know Randy well din with lastek
yeah sweetheart of a guy um Randy has a
saying he always says the little things
aren't the big things the little things
are everything yeah and I want you to
think about what I'm going to say right
now is a little thing that you've heard
before but what I notice in all of them
the one thing I have in commment is
they'll have a story and the story is
about the size of the they can have
right so I don't know about you but I
had limiting stories right we all have
right that the the voice of saying you
don't have education you didn't come
front takes money to make money but then
I found a new story it says no I could
start my own Collision Center and then
you get a breakthrough to that my
Collision Center is going and I'm doing
a half a million dollars in sales and
I'm making a hundred grand a year it's
like oh my God but when you get there if
you keep that story it's not enough to
get you to a million right and yes you
need the tactics you need the
capabilities you need a new way of
thinking the you know the the business
that got you out of Egypt and the
business philosophies is not the same
one takes you to the promised land right
we got to evolve all our thinking you
have to self-educate so many people
think they go to school for five six
seven years that's it for the rest of
their life you got to educate non-stop
right but what I notice is a lot of them
that are stuck will have a story that's
actually keeping them stuck there and
that that's can sound pretty foofoo and
like oh I've heard that before but at
next time and I'm I'm I'm obsessed with
this cuz I all people say damn Dean now
you're you know Tony and I launched a
business we did the biggest launch in
Internet history it's become a yeah it's
become a movement people like how did
you jump into that and do it CU I
carried with me all the capabilities I
changed a new story I just want to tell
you my story for the education system is
in within 20 years Tony Robbins and I
will create an alternative to the
traditional education system and will'll
make them evolve instead of put I'm not
trying to put them out of business
they'll go oh damn these guys are taking
our business they'll evolve and secondly
we'll make self-education the new Norm
where people when they're getting
interviewed they'll say okay who did you
self-educate with who did you Mentor
under what Workshop did you go to oh I
went through this oh great come on in
right that's my goal so I have a new
story that's massive and it's Patrick
it's literally pulling me out of bed in
the morning right now if I had a story
that said dude you're lucky you got here
you had dyslexia you didn't go to school
your brand has done all that you got
this big house you got money dude you
should like like be careful you don't
want to lose it if I kept that story
there's no way I would have done that
right so I had a upgrade my story and
people right now might be listening go
oh yeah that's what rich people say it's
not I wish someone would have shaken me
at a younger age I'd be so much further
ahead and say the story you're telling
yourself let me hear it come on give it
to me right now and you think it's
empowering but then when you dissect you
go oh that's why I'm stuck you need new
story upgrade your story upgrade your
life so what's interesting is that and
you can see the purpose in it and you
know so I feel the vision of how you're
understanding self-education and
literally one of the things that's
preventing a a breakthrough in humanity
is is a very old Antiquated system of
educating people which is literally
counterproductive to them expressing
their genius in a world that's so full
of wealth and resources that that old
factory style education is no longer
necessary just think what if your
daughter didn't have you guys as parents
yeah right what if she had a parent not
bad loves her to death but was so
ingrained in traditional you're an
entrepreneur you're a Visionary you work
on yourself on a deep level I you know
it's and I I love hearing great stories
about you I do you touch a lot of
people's lives in such a great way dude
I mean it um but you're you're heart
centered you and your wife so you
recognize that you did it but just think
what if you forced your daughter and
said get to school get good grades
you're going to get grounded where would
she be compared to you probably fast
forward 5 years now she's going to be
leaning into who she is singing in front
of thousands of people making people
have experiences through her music
through her impact and change in the
world right same person that's right
just different stories different stories
just different stories so and education
is the path to writing a new story it's
creating a new story right which is just
amazing so I'm like overly excited and
stimulated because I know when you're
talking about this big vision of
Shifting the system it's not like some
um abstract you know goal that is like
you're just reaching for the Stars you
mean it yeah I mean it I believe we're
going to do it and so does Tony I think
I think if two people could do it we
could I hope we can help you I really
love that so listen um I can't express
my gratitude for you to come here to
share all this I know it's going to make
a big difference for the people who are
watching and I am just Uber excited for
what you're going to be creating in the
future so thanks so much for this time
and effort you got man I appreciate
[Music]
you okay now we're going to hit the
breaks and shift from Dean's infectious
enthusiasm to the Stark reality of money
in America today author journalist and
former managing director at Goldman
Sachs noi Prince resume is second to
none no one I know has a better
understanding of the secrets Wall Street
hopes you never learn than know me she's
a genius you need to listen to you need
to watch what you're about to see very
closely and I recommend you take notes
because Nomi is about to show you how
you can know in advance when markets
could crash and also reveal the Dark
Truth About Central Bank manipulation of
our money sometimes the biggest wealth
breakthrough is simply protecting what
you have right now in the face of an
unknown future here's my colleague Jeff
Hayes's incredible conversation with
nomi nomi thank you so much for being
here with us I've really been looking
forward to this interview um we've spent
a long time chasing you cuz we really
really wanted to have have you in this
tell us a little bit about who you are
what you do and how you got
here um well I am currently a bunch of
things um I I am a journalist I'm an
author um I have a trading newsletter um
actually a couple and I also work with
different um governments throughout the
world on on on policies that can
hopefully make uh the economy and and
sort of the financial system fairer for
more people um and that's kind of my day
job I did come from a wild Street
background um as well as a city of
London background I basically graduated
um college with a uh math degree um and
was recruited into sort of a programming
analyst position at Chase and from there
I went on to a number of different
institutions two of which exist now two
of which went bust in the 2008 crisis
but I went through Leman Brothers um bar
Sterns and Goldman Sachs um where I was
a managing director and at beern before
that I had run an analytics team um that
did International analytics and um all
sorts of mathy things um for for trading
and investment strategies for
institutional investors around the world
um and then after Goldman um where I
left slightly after 911 I I then went on
to this this new phase of my life where
I I basically um talk about it more
towards the public as opposed to just
institutional investors through the sort
of Wall Street or banking Arena so
there's a big divide between what Wall
Street knows and what the average person
knows what where how are you bridging
that divide for people so it's it's
funny cuz going back in time to uh when
I was at Goldman before I left Goldman
um what was going on at the time were a
number of things one of which was 911 um
which was a tremendously um sort of
obviously visceral experience for
everyone um who was in New York and
really around the world at the time but
I was a few blocks away from the towers
at Goldman Sachs while that was
happening that was a very pivotal uh
time in my life and I left um the
banking Arena terms of Wall Street
shortly thereafter um but during that
time as well there were a lot of
corporate scandals that were going on um
there was the Enron Scandal which was a
big Energy company meltdown um there was
the Worldcom Scandal which was a
telecom's uh meltdown as were other
telecom companies as were other energy
companies at the time and just a spade
of corporate fraud um that was aided and
embedded to a large extent by Wall
Street practices um and at the time I
actually wound up talking to a
journalist um at the financial times who
was asking me a lot of questions about
what was going on he was very focused on
energy in general what was happening
with those companies as they were um
corrupting and melting down and
ultimately under investigations and so
forth and um I wasn't allowed to really
talk about the relationship between
Goldman Sachs and and Enron at this time
but I did give him a lot of um
information about just in general what
was going on and we talked and talked
through when I left Wall Street slightly
thereafter and he said you know what you
you need to talk more about this to the
rest of the world cuz we don't know
there's such a cloak around Wall Street
the language of Wall Street the money of
Wall Street um the fact that trading
desks move so much money around the
world in nanc all the time that most of
the public has no knowledge of and and
and most of the public also doesn't even
know how it impacts them um and and
someone needs to talk about that so I
kind of took on this role of all right
well I wanted to do other things with my
life he's like you know you you should
write something um and so my first job
that he actually um got me as a
journalist was a Fortune Magazine and so
I'm going from being a managing director
of Goldman Sachs where I've got a corner
office on a high floor I got two teams
of people reporting to me um all this
you know money coming in through that um
you know through just the Wall Street
mechanism through Goldman Sachs and I
quit to become a journalist and the
first job I have is as an assistant
writer on a piece for Fortune Magazine
on a company called Global Crossing
which was a big meltdown fraud in the
telecommunication space and I used to go
and get coffee for the senior writer so
again going from managing director to
like going down and bringing up the
coffee um and I was perfectly happy with
that because it just enabled me to
really be honest and truthful with my
opinions and doing analysis of what was
going on in the real world and knowing
it would go out to the public it would
go out to real readers and sort of that
was the first moment um that I did that
switch and from there on I I continued
to speak and to write um books and
articles um and at Arenas throughout the
world on on what goes on and how that
impct s the overall world I'm fascinated
by the 2007 2008 um you know crash
debacle that you know this is one that
that really played out in everyone's
lives and I I don't think it's been
completely understood so I I actually
wrote a book on the beginning of the
explanation of of that crisis called it
takes a pillage um which came out in
2009 and and it was interesting cuz I
had at that point um decided to try
again to change and get out of the
financial industry or at least even
about writing about it for a minute and
I I had moved to Los Angeles to to work
on writing for um what didn't happen but
what was going to be an urban superhero
called The Lost Angel so I was working
with a bunch of people down in Downtown
LA on that and all of a sudden the
financial crisis is looking worse and
worse I am still writing articles and I
noticed at the end of 2007 middle 2007
that there was a lot of debt that was
piled on and a lot of not just the
lenders but also the developers of these
major sort of housing establishment
cities like throughout Miami and and
Vegas and and different sort of hubs
where housing had been cheap but had
bubbled up um and that they were
starting to lose money and the Insiders
were starting to sell their stock and
that was going to be a signal that
something bad was going to happen
because the reason that was going on is
because people who had gone subprime and
other types of mid Prime mortgages were
finding it difficult to to repay those
those terms in those mortgages but in
the meantime it was really Wall Street
who took those mortgages um those
subprime mortgages and created these
whole other Securities bundling them up
reselling them slicing dicing them in
multiple different ways so just in
financial terms you had a situation of
kind of like an upside down pyramid
where at the the bottom point of the
triangle of that pyramid was like one
little subprime mortgage of you know one
little family and say Fremont California
and then above that there were all these
Securities that were relied on that
payment to act as if it was paying all
these other Securities up the triangle
and up the Wall Street chain and all the
companies um that were creating these
other Securities that relied on this one
mortgage on mortgage upon mortgage upon
mortgage were making all of this money
selling all of these pieces of that
pyramid up the chain around the world um
and and ultimately that that can't hold
you cannot have something that is
basically stabilized on a single point
you know sort of uplift everything
that's happening at what is the base of
the triangle at the top that just
doesn't work and ultimately the
financial crisis happened because when
any of those mortgages stopped being
able to make payments all the payments
that were expected upon all the
Securities that required those payments
to come in on this whole upside down
pyramid of money also weren't getting
what they thought they would get and
that meant they couldn't sell across
Wall Street anymore that couldn't sell
across the world to Pension funds to
insurance companies or anything else all
over the world anymore and the liquidity
stopped the markets just crunched down
um and that was when Banks basically
went into Washington and said look you
know we are effectively going to be
unable to make payments on these
Securities on the options that we took
out against these Securities on the
insurance we took out on our own
Securities all of those payments are not
coming into us so we can't make payments
on the other side and so that's why
there was a bailout that was required
that's why there was a meltdown and
that's why ultimately um central banks
like the Fed Reserve came in to
effectively subsidize those losses and
those decisions to create the upside
down pyramid on a mega Global basis to
me it looks like we had a
consequence that we averted that we you
know stepped around but I can't help but
think that there's a consequence that
maybe just got pushed down what do the
effects of this bailout on so so all
this depends on first considering what
the initial bailout was to be and that
was to be a $700 billion package um that
was approved by by by the US government
that would go to the major banks that
were involved in creating these these
Securities these toxic assets out of the
pieces of subprime mortgages that were
in them and to enable them to
effectively pay each other on all of the
insurances um that had been taken out
against these these Securities in the
event that subprime mortgages didn't pay
out but there wasn't enough money to do
that and that's why they needed the
bailout they got that bailout they used
it to um effectively make themselves
whole for that very small period of time
now you could look at that and and a lot
of people have looked at that as being
the period of a crisis being averted
because here the banks were about to
sort of run out of liquidity daily
operational money because they had to
back all these bump Securities that they
created and that there was no trust to
buy and sell in a Marketplace anymore
because they didn't have the value that
they were proposed to have but there was
a major ramification after that which is
that ultimately the banks didn't have
enough liquidity to go beyond that
either and so that's why the Federal
Reserve stepped in it reduced interest
rates to zero so it reduced the cost of
money to Banks not to people but to
Banks um to effectively 0% interest the
idea being that Banks could get the
money that they needed um through
something called the Federal Reserve
window and continue if there are
problems along the way as the aftermath
the aftershocks of this particular $700
billion bailout period and and be okay
but that actually wasn't enough money it
wasn't enough for them to get what was
available at 0% they needed more and so
what the Federal Reserve did and
ultimately organized other major central
banks around the world to do is
something called quantitative easing and
that's a wonky way of saying that they
electronically created money they gave
it to the banks they allowed the banks
to get rid of some of the Securities
that they couldn't otherwise get rid of
because they had not the value that the
FED gave them money for
that basically overvalue the Securities
that were sinking on the books of these
Banks and that kept going and going and
going for what is now 11 years um in
different ways QE stopped it started
there were different bonds that the US
um Federal Reserve bought versus the
European Central Bank in Europe bought
versus the bank of Japan bought from all
of their respective banks in their
respective countries But ultimately what
they did was they produced
electronically $22 trillion worth of
money out of of nowhere in order to buy
debts and bad or weaken Securities from
these banks with the idea that these
Banks would then have this extra money
lend it to people and the economy would
start turning again what really happened
was we got a lot of bubbles in financial
assets like the bond market like the
stock market like in certain real estate
markets because that money went into
very selective Pockets it really went
into investors and speculators and a
very small group of society as opposed
to the overall
economic environment which is why even
though economic growth did increase
after the crisis during the crisis it
had become negative um it's never really
gotten super healthy to the point where
the fed and these central banks can take
away that money can be like okay we want
our $22 trillion back because that's not
happening what's happening instead is we
are pushing that problem down the road
we're pushing more debt to be created
because rates are so cheap it doesn't
cost that much for institutions and
governments to borrow money and worry
about paying it back later the interest
rates are low to negative in some cases
um the stock market's up and that looks
really great to a lot of people
especially people that are involved in
the stock market but that's not
everybody that's not even by a long shot
everybody um but it also means we're
pushing that problem and making it
bigger down the road because without
that support that $22 trillion from the
major central banks in the world all of
that shrivels and implodes really
quickly so from what you're describing
it it seems to me at some point there
ought to be a reckoning is you know is
that the the end of this game is that is
there a reckoning that happens so it's
interesting because um when I wrote my
my first book after Wall Street was
called other people's money the
corporate mugging of America and it
relates back to all of those scandals um
in the energy and Telecom sector that
were enabled by the banking sector and
how that all happened and and created a
major recession at the time as well as a
lot of fraud um but one of the things I
said in that book is without a serious
change like a systematic change to the
regulations of banks um which at the
time and still I mean um something
called the glass deagle act which would
have separated the the banking banking
structure um in such a way that Banks
could not within the same
institution lend money to real people
and take deposits from real people and
use that money to create much riskier
Securities on another part of their
company on another part of their books
and so without some idea of of
basically a real wall between those two
types of activities we were going to
have a crisis because Banks were just
going to use this money that was here
and that was government guaranteed to
produce all this risk take money off the
top and go about their day and
ultimately get bailed out and that is
what happened I wrote that book in 2004
that's what happened in the 20072 2008
crisis what we're seeing now and where
there could be a reckoning but it's it
might take some time is that a central
banks continue to manufacture money and
to put money into the system at sort of
its upper echelon so so so high level
Financial assets the banks um private
Equity Funds Etc that that have the
wherewithal to get it cheaper um as well
as countries that have the wherewithal
to get it cheaper um that can continue
as long as central banks continue to
provide it cheaply central banks haven't
been able to get an exit plan that
allows them to take that money away as I
mentioned before which means that even
though at some point companies that are
too highly indebted governments that are
too highly indebted relative to their
own growth whether that's National
growth or or corporate growth will at
some point not be able to pay back those
debts but as long as those debts are
cheap to come by they'll continue to
accumulate them and so it's not until
there is a point where the growth is so
slow to negative that it becomes so
difficult to pay even the cheapest debts
that we do have another crisis and it
could be worse than um a recession or
the financial crisis because it could be
a major Global depression um where we're
ways away from that even though that is
in The Ether because central banks are
continuing to sort of enable governments
and companies to sort of tread water so
it's a question of how long that that
water treading exercise can go on before
the energy just gets sapped out of it
meaning those debts can't be repaid even
though they are so cheap um that could
be a year that could be two years that
could be 5 years that could be 10 years
and the reason for that is because
central banks have no um regulatory or
legislative any sort of limits on the
amount of money they can produce and
inject into the financial system and so
as long as they have no limits which
they won't for political reasons um they
kind of can continue this this Treading
Water process but what that also means
is that people real people don't
necessarily feel the impact of all of
that money that has been put into the
system you we talk about high level
economic growth being 2% 2.3% 1.9%
whatever it is it's not great but also
that's at a higher level that's not
really considering the fact that a lot
of people still live paycheck to
paycheck especially when you go on
throughout the world and a lot of them
are very indebted um with their own
individual debts whether that's student
loans or household or medical or
whatever it might be um and so those are
the people that haven't had as much as
of an upside in the General stock market
growth and and other types of growth
that that's sort of touted as being
prevalent yeah it it almost feels like
um you know a garden is is growing and
and
it's like one area for some reason is
being overwater over fertilized and is
really flourishing and the rest of the
garden is not doing as well but um you
know the the the work is going into it
so the this Central Bank you made a
comment that there's no real
governmental Insight over the central
banks I think you're I'd really like for
you to explain the the central bank it's
almost a question of okay what is money
and where where does it come from um the
central bank's role in that and and
you're not just talking about the fed
you say you know I I guess we're
worldwide um yeah it's it's a global
phenomenon because what happened after
the financial crisis um like right then
is that it wasn't just a Federal Reserve
that came in and bailed out the US Banks
or even the global banks that were
working with the US Banks on
Distributing these toxic assets it was
it was it was bigger than that and
that's why it it it rolled out to a $22
trillion quantitative easing sort of
subsidization package to the financial
system throughout multiple um major
central banks it wasn't enough for the
FED to just do what it did it needed the
European Central Bank it needed the bank
of Japan because it needed um all of the
major central banks throughout the world
that operated as most banks do with a
lot of dollars um in their Arsenal as
well as Banks operating with dollars in
their Arsenal to to really make the
problem look like it was going away so
the analogy of a lot of stuff is being
watered which is the sort of private
major Private Bank um and and major
governments Community sort of in the
front of the picture um and then it's
sort of like that's that's what's the on
the on the lawn side you know that's
your um Street appeal side um then in
the back of that you have all of the
other layers of of countries of people
um and of other types of companies that
have gone underwater that that haven't
gotten
watered um or haven't gotten that money
so we've we've kind of done a big
picture and we've done a a
historical uh what do you see happening
right now what what what's your your
sense so so right now it's it depends on
on which asset class we're looking at
but from the standpoint for example of
the stock market um obviously in the US
we have these record levels um but
there's also this sort of in inner sense
of um tension within some of those
levels and and how they level up which
is that there's a lot of volatility or
movement on an interday basis or or like
on different days throughout the week
it's not kind of a smooth Trend um and a
lot of that is because there is an
expectation that this this money from
central banks will somehow continue to
be there last year central banks decid
or at least the FED did to raise rates
throughout the year that didn't work out
so well and this year they kind of
reverse course and they're reducing
rates um and other countries are keeping
them negative and that means that the
markets have a sort of bolster
underneath them but with this tension
with this volatility in between so for
example what I do is not invest in the
stock market as a sort of long-term
thing what what I tend to do because
that movement is inherent right now in
the period that we're in right now um is
I tend to trade more in and out not like
day trading all the time but just on a
more sort of periodic basis as the
Market's moving up and down in this
volatile period and sort of take money
off of the table and set it aside in in
sort of a cash type of environment um
one of the other things that that I uh
do and and tell people to do um for
example in their own savings is to look
for places where they can get interest
rates above on their savings accounts
above what these major banks give them
which is basically close to nothing so
even after 11 years of getting all this
cheap or you know basically 0% interest
on average money from the FED um they
don't tend to give back um to their
customers to an extent they just
basically don't pay that much on savings
accounts but there are places online um
in particular in banking where you can
get higher um rates on savings and even
if that's 2% it's still better than
closer to 0% so if you're keeping
something on the side um that's just a
better way to do that similarly on on
debt there's such a range um in terms of
of credit cards right now at the moment
we're at some of the highest average
levels of of credit card rates even
though rates are so so low for the banks
that are coming by this money that they
are lending out through credit cards um
that we've ever been at and so it's
important to look at um all of the ways
to chop down debt and all of the ways to
particularly chop down the debt that um
incurs the highest amount of interest
rates and that sounds really basic but a
lot of people don't think of doing that
um they just kind of let things roll and
whether it's paying a minimum payment or
just not switching cards out or not
closing cards that are too high on
interest rates to to move them elsewhere
or find savings um accounts that have
higher payouts um all of these things
are incremental changes that kind of set
you up for this volatile period uh you
know so reducing your expenses and
increasing the the money that you can
get on your savings um and then from an
investment standpoint um to invest in
things that that you actually use you
know whether that is your home um
whether that is um you know sort of a
boat or a car or or just something that
you absolutely need versus what you
actually want in this period that's kind
of more volatile I'm not saying
everybody needs a boat but it really
just depends on what your what what you
do with your life but but the point is
that you you know that you look at the
bigger assets that you buy as things
that you actually can either use that
you actually need to use or that you can
rent out um and so to look at that as
sort of one pool of asset class during
this period um look at keeping money off
of the more volatile parts of the market
and when you are investing in those
volatile Parts get in and get out to
reflect that volatility and then sort of
like stay in your resting spot you know
it's funny my sense of this period um is
is not um gloomy it's like I feel like
there's a lot of opportunity and this is
just a personal feeling this is not
based on like you actually have reasons
for the things you do my personal view
is there's lots of opportunity but I
sense that winter is coming so what it
it it I I like your description of of of
how to approach this
is as not using stocks right now or the
market right now as a longterm but being
in and out if somebody wants to follow
that strategy um can you give us some
guidepost how how are how are you doing
it what you know what are you look for
even earlier you mentioned in like in
2003 the book you wrote about you
noticed a lot of Insider sales is that
one of the indicators you look for of
Insider selling stock or what what are
your indicators look at um Insider
selling I look at um the debt ratios
that that some of these companies have
because again even though debt is
cheaper today than than it's been for
companies or governments just
historically um it's it's still
important to be liquid and and to have
not that incurrence of debt in case
something bad happens to the company so
I tend to look at companies that aren't
leading um with debt even though it is
available on their balance sheet or the
companies that themselves have a pretty
good cash um stockpile uh you know for
example like a Warren Buffet who puts
like so much cash on the side right now
um and a lot of sort of people like that
who um are saving that money on the side
and I I I do think that to an extent
mirroring that as an individual investor
um has a lot of Merit you know because
it does mean that you can um actually
both look for companies that do that and
also kind of footprint that in your own
life so there there's a sense of of just
balancing um those two things in terms
of investing and in terms of of saving
and sort of holding down the fort um at
home so let's talk about women for a
minute because I know this is important
to you for to help women level up that
they you know first you know men don't
get much Financial education if any at
all and women get even less and so I'm
picturing a woman sitting at home and
there's opportunity about it what does
she need to learn what do people need to
learn about Finance to safely to enter
the markets to take advantage of the
opportunities I think for women in
particular because we don't always um
feel as women that it's our thing to be
as on top of finances relative to just
other things in life let's say um that
they're sort of there but we're not as
necessarily um in touch with all of
their specifics and so I think the very
first thing to do before one invests or
even to invest more um if depending on
what level um she's at is to look at
your current statements and and L this
is what I what I say when I talk to
groups of of women like the first thing
you want to do is you want to get out
your credit card statements you want to
get out your bank accounts if you have
mutual funds for whatever you have get
them on the table like literally get
them on the table you know whether
that's your electronic table your
physical table whatever but and and and
just literally take a look at you know
what fees banks are charging you just to
literally keep your money with them you
know what savings rates they're not
paying you just to keep your money with
them what bills you're paying on like
magazines you subscribed to like five
years ago in some like internet like
rush to you that you don't even read
ever um you know what credit cards do
you have that are up at their 29% limit
because in the fine print after 18
months that's what was going to happen
um and and literally just pair down um
and then depending on what your own
personal dat to um money on the side
ratio is and and what your money coming
in and going out is in terms of what you
need to do um try to negotiate or get
rid of some of that debt I've had um
women that I've spoke to and it's been
really gratifying actually um who didn't
do this yet and then decided to do it
you know spend the hour or two or maybe
it's an afternoon and I know we're all
busy but just to kind of get that
straight um and have come back and
negotiated some of their debt with their
credit card companies down a lot which
allow them to not for example use
outside sort of credit bundlers which I
just don't believe in at all for the
whole other topic of conversation and
literally be like okay look I owe you X
I want to pay you y or I want this rate
to be reduced or I'm going to move it to
another credit card company or whatever
to just reduce their outgoings you know
to to canceling stuff they're not using
like reduce your outgoing look at what
you have that what you don't need right
away to use and and make it go further
first by Saving then we'll get into the
investing part um then you get into the
investing and then it's a it's a series
of things and it really depends on your
education level at the time but you can
for example learn about the stock market
by buying one share in one thing that
you use so literally if something you do
um requires you know if you like Health
Foods um or or something like that there
a particular brand that that you
actually buy and like and you see in the
stores you may want to just Google some
of the information on that and just see
if buying one share gets you into the
idea of being in the stock market then
you sort of go from there on the
educational um basis and that goes up
and up I I tend to I I trade options um
because I I understand them and I've had
experience and I've learned them but
those are ways of of increasing the
return in a shorter period of time of
what your investment and share could be
so share on Amazon is like way too
expensive for a real normal person um
however an option in Amazon is something
that's affordable so so then it depends
on how you increase your knowledge level
in terms of the types of Investments um
that you take on and people can follow
you trading online I mean you have stuff
that I mean I do have um I do have a
couple of new newletter products um that
um are are available um I have something
called the 25 cent Trader that's
available as well as something called
Dark Money Millionaires which is kind of
a takeoff on this dark money that the
central banks are putting into the
system and and where that pops up in
terms of uh more the institutional or
professional trading community and and
how um that can help to shape your own
investment strategy so I have um those
two things and I also just have a lot of
books out because I I think in order to
invest it's also important to understand
the general economy and also to an
extent that what's happening in the
world and I know that sounds like a lot
but but just literally it's like
learning a new language it's like or
even English like if you learn a new
word you know then all of a sudden you
keep on coming up to that word in in
conversation again and again it's like
oh I just learned that word and now it's
everywhere like who knew and the same
thing with any type of language it's
like that in finance and so I think it's
important and I I I have many books on
this um as there is information
available from other people to
understand like um a little bit about
sort of Wall Street a little bit of what
is the Fed you know what what are
central banks not because they
necessarily impact one's daily life
directly but because they have a severe
impact indirectly and it's just useful
to know things um before you go and and
and do them because it just gives you a
better experience and background and
what I've noticed for example in my
books I don't write them for manner for
women but I have noticed that that um a
lot of the people that buy my books when
you look at
um the other kinds of books they buy
like Amazon takes a track of oh you know
if you like bought this book you'll like
these books they tend to all be written
um by men so there's not a lot of women
writing on just the general economy and
general uh Financial systemic
information there there are women
writing on sort of financial advice and
so I I just think it's important to
Marry the two um and just to know just
be aware of what's going on and I think
women in particular are really good at
multitasking that kind of stuff anyway
um but I just think it's important to to
reach out sort of take some moments to
gather information about what's going on
generally um as well as then looking at
your individual situation so then this
may be too personal and you don't have
to to go here if you want but I I
couldn't help but Wonder as you're
talking about corner office Goldman
Sachs high up um you know rooms of
people and I I know the income that um
you know that Goldman rewards its people
really well going from that to being a
journalist to you know to where you are
now can you is is there you know were
there traps you stepped in where there
was it a a nice smooth ride from you
know one high to the next Peak or what
um it it certainly is the case that you
do not make as much money as a
journalist as you do as an investment
banker um I was under no kind of
Illusion about that although my mom at
the time was like you did what you quit
where what really um but you know I I
had a lot of personal reasons for making
that shift and I'm very glad I did what
a couple things both enabled me to do it
and and also sort of um fell upon me
during um the year since I I quit Wall
Street um going into it I I had always
been pretty prudent um as I suggest for
people to do with the money I did make
um as I was just just even you know
initially as a junior analyst working at
Chase throughout um when when I left
Goldman and I I didn't tend to overspend
I I always felt like even if I bought
property which I kind of did along the
way and I kind of would move it into
different places as I moved around the
world I I would put 40 to 50% down
otherwise I wouldn't buy it like there
there was ways that I kind of um used
the money that I was making um as I was
suggesting earlier in our conversation
which is in things that can be continue
to be of use to me or that could be
rented out or or or in that capacity
didn't over extend me um and because I
never really overextended myself or I
tried not to overextend myself it
allowed me to have money aside that
enabled me to be a journalist for what
is now a long time um because again it's
it's not the same sort of money um
aspect however there's a couple things
that I can just recall off the top in
terms of Pitfall so one of the things
that I had as savings was something I
couldn't touch which was options on
stock and bare Sterns um where I had
worked seven years and had ran on inter
International analytics group in in
London um and that was kind of going to
be on the side that was going to be my
retirement it was sort of in a plan um
that be Sterns had created that like you
couldn't kind of touch it was there it
accumulated and even if you left the
company it was there in that plan um so
when I went to Goldman it was still
there but in the financial crisis um the
value of what that stock was behind
those options G you know went from $68
to to $2 and so as a result my entire
you know sort of what I thought was
going to be my future saving things was
just gone um and so that was kind of an
Awakening moment um as a result of which
I I had to sell the place I was living
in and actually got me to move to
California and I got a place that was
cheaper because that's what I could
afford um to continue to build to
rebuild up but so you little things like
that happened along the way where um you
know you expect money to be there and
then it's just not and and then it's a
question of sort of recalibrating but
it's easier to recalibrate if you
haven't been too overextended and so I
did wind up selling a place but I did it
into the financial crisis so so again
there there there was a a a loss to an
extent there but at the same time
because I wasn't as overextended I I
managed to at least make that last you
know sort of through the year since I I
like the uh your mentality that um you
can take your retirement that's locked
up in be Sterns options that go from 68
to two and and refer to it as little
things like that so that may that that
that you know that suggests the right U
mentality and and the fact that you've
given yourself such a base that allows
you to
withstand what you know for some people
I'm sure was
um devastating that is a good point in
terms of how I characterized it um and
it and and it was and and a lot of that
was from how I had sort of managed what
I was getting in up until that point but
it was also I think my reaction to what
happened which is that I can't wait
around for this to change I I I I had to
do other moves in my life to enable me
to sort of Bounce out of that um and and
and so I was very fortunate to to have
it I was also afraid of what could
happen um in the future and and so as a
result um that that that fast transition
I think enabled me also to to to move
from that point let's talk just briefly
about trading options um because that
for a lot of people people you know
options you can lose all your money you
know that's that's kind of it's riskier
um how do you how what is your strategy
that you're using on trading options and
how much of your activity is related to
that so first of all I a very small
amount of of what I have um is what I
risk on options trading even though I
know a lot about options trading um so
so in general um A good rule of thumb is
to never um you you know sort of invest
or speculate with what you can't afford
to to lose um and the corer to that is
to be able to quantify that loss so you
know what you're talking about that's
like you don't go into Vegas and sit
down at a blackjack table with like an
open checkbook some people do that's not
a good strategy um and so I would say a
very small portion of of of what I have
um I even use um in terms of my trading
in the options Market but I also in
terms of option Strate IES um I I never
allow myself to be exposed more than
what I know so for example I um I only
buy options I don't I don't short them
so I don't I don't run the risk of um
what could happen if a position goes way
against me and I have to sort of figure
out how to make up for that loss I know
exactly what my loss is so if I buy a 20
cent option um I know that at most I'm
going to lose that amount of money 20
cents times um however many contracts I
bought um and so I'm I'm evaluating the
risk of of the loss before I enter the
trade so that's one thing like
considering what that downside value is
to me and then over the course of an
options portfolio just incorporating
that knowledge with how I trade and in
terms of um how I look at the upside
there's a lot of things that I look at
in terms of even selecting um which
option which name which day um and how
much to put into it so if I don't feel
like there is based on my analysis a
tremendous amount of upside I'm not also
going to invest a tremendous amount of
that portion of the money that I've set
aside to trade so I I actually have a
very rules-based strategy on what I do
and I tend not to or at least I try not
to get emotional about it so I'm I'm I'm
actually comfortable taking losses that
I've been able to calculate Could Happen
um more comfortable taking gains um but
but in terms of balancing those two
things um I I tend to stay within my my
rle so I I I don't tend to for example
put on new positions at the end of the
day because for the most part the
institutional trading at the end of the
day is is harder to recognize in terms
of patterns and so I don't think for
example it's a good time to trade so the
few times I've ignored my own advice
haven't been great trades so it's like
okay well just listen remember what you
said to yourself um you only trade in
the morning so I I I only tend to trade
now in the first half an hour um in the
morning occasionally it bleeds into an
hour depending on what's going on but
that's when I notice the most amount of
of momentum and volume going into the
way that I trade which is that I want to
be in and out I don't want to hang out
um and I don't want to not watch so so
the way I trade is based on both the way
I organize my time but also the the
activity in the market that's also when
a lot the institutional buyers and
sellers are in in and out as well so I'm
taking advantage of kind of what I know
they're doing and what I see them doing
from the standpoint of the market itself
to where I feel comfortable trading and
then I I keep a very solid if it goes
down by 20% like you're out of the trade
and I'm fine about that you know if it
if it goes up by a certain percentage I
I Bank the rest um that upside and then
I sort of move on it sounds like you've
done really well at establishing some
parameters some some rules for yourself
um it also sounds like you know if
you're doing trading in the morning and
you're also allowing to have a life yeah
that uh this is not a bad way uh to live
is have some really solid parameters
and know what you're doing but also not
let it consume you from sun up to sun
down well I think um and this goes back
to my Wall Street days that everybody
was pretty much consumed by their number
by the money by the Bonus by what they
were going to make that quarter and how
they were going to sort of move it up
the ladder to Senior Management to get
that bonus and it's a very um external
way to live it's the same thing with
trading I could sit there and and and
watch my screens all day long but I
wouldn't get articles written I wouldn't
learn stuff I wouldn't be outside I
wouldn't you know hang out with my dogs
or do yoga or just anything else it also
sort of balances actual life um and and
one of the things that I did get from
leaving Wall Street was that ability to
have more control over prioritizing my
own life not that things you know we
can't control everything and that's
probably not good that's just weird but
but just just the ability to have those
hours where I could consider what it is
I want to do and whether that's a
long-term project like a book um whether
that's something short like an article
or or giving a speech or or whatever it
might be or whether that's trading a
half an hour once or twice a week all of
that is yes part of that sort of bigger
picture of balance so no me what are you
excited about now what's next for you so
as I look at prioritizing um this next
year we're already into almost 2020 but
when 2020 begins and and sort of unfolds
um is is really I'm honestly looking at
three things in terms of my top
priorities for the first at least six
months of the year because I do travel a
lot I do a lot of talks I I am going
constantly um in the background of
prioritizing everything else and um one
of the major issue um initiatives that I
have is um to work more to get women to
be more knowledgeable and proactive
about their own finances um I did start
a series called no money um in La
actually of of monthly salons with women
um of different levels of knowledge
about money and about finance and
different backgrounds different ages
careers Etc um where each month was
honing in on a particular topic whether
that was debt whether that was savings
whether that was the stock market um the
outside economy and so forth so
collectively um there is an entire
picture after a series of six to seven
months of kind of the the main things
and tools um that that I think women
should spend more time on or or or um
incorporate more into their General
language um in life and in finance and
with their money um and I'm going to be
creating with um Kim kosaki um a video
series on these elements where she's
also incorporating her elements you know
she's she's a major uh she's CEO of of
of the Rich Dad franchise she's also a
major real estate investor and so forth
and also um very much cares about
getting more women into this sort of
knowledge based and and activity based
in in money and finance and so we're
going to create a video series um as
well to to be accessible um to more
women as as one of many um initiatives
uh during this year to help to increase
um awareness and and and use of of
Finance for women so I'm very excited
about about that we're going to be
actually filming um throughout the
beginning of 2020 and hopefully
releasing that later and and sort of
offshoots from that good for you I can't
thank you enough for being here I really
appreciate you taking the time thank you
so
much
[Music]
the big names keep piling up from Nomi
prins we move on to Tim Sykes one of the
most popular widely known and yes
controversial traders in America today
Tim started in the market with $12,000
and turned it into 4.8 million over the
next two decades he's also going to talk
about how it's possible to make 50 times
your money in a single trade the more
unbelievable what Tim says might seem
the closer you should pay attention
because Tim students have seen their
lives changed by his advice time and
time again pay close attention to this
one Jeff's interview with Tim starts
right now Tim thanks so much for being
here we've already had some fun so I
think this is probably going to be great
so tell me who you are and what is it
that you do sure um you know I'm a stock
Trader and a teacher and a traveler um I
got started my bar mitzvah money roughly
12 Grand in high school my parents gave
me control of it um I was a tennis
player but I got injured so they gave me
control thinking I would lose it all put
it into the stock market but senior year
of high school I got obsessed with
trying to figure out patterns in the
stock market and I made over 100,000 um
and then freshman year in college I made
over $700,000 so I was hooked because
I'm from a middle- class neighborhood so
this was big money and since then I just
keep trading I made over $5 million now
and I teach and I have five millionaire
students so far 57 schools with my
charity Foundation traveling all over
the world been to 125 countries loving
life well that's not how old are you
right now I'm 38 that is not a bad life
for a 38y old human being it's a star
you know but I trade with a small
account because I trade low price stocks
so you can't make billions of dollars um
that's part of the reason why I teach
because I make a few hundred dollars a
few thousand doar from places like Bali
um and I can trade from anywhere so a
lot of my social media is just like me
on my laptop in beautiful places and I'm
like look at how beautiful this is
laptop lifestyle I actually saw a video
of you maybe six months ago from Venice
yeah I was in one of those um those
boats right and like I was on my laptop
and like people were like what are you
doing I'm like laptop lifestyle it's
amazing so and you say more importantly
you say you're a teacher yeah so how do
you teach people yeah so I mean I've
been doing this 20 years now I got
started in high school like I said so
I've seen good companies back companies
um I've created a lot of trading rules
so you can basically see my screen um I
have a chat room I have video lessons I
have 6,000 video lessons because I have
too many lessons to talk about um good
trades bad trades and I show everything
just what I've learned and so these are
low price stocks or they the that's what
you specialize in yeah I mean pretty
much the whole world hates on them and
they've made me Rich and now several of
my top students Rich because the world
hates on them because they don't
understand them they think okay if
you're going to invest in these
companies they're all going to crash
which is true but I don't invest I trade
I know that they're going to crash I
know that most of them are going to fail
like 99% of them fail right have you
seen Wolf of Wall Street it's like those
companies but what you don't know is
that in the meantime before they fail
their stocks can rise 200 300 500 even a
th% in a few days and also crash in a
few days so I ride the volatility I go
to long and I go short this pump kind of
pump and dump pattern um if you know
that a stock is being promoted you know
the Wolf of Wall Street was before the
internet but now there's a lot of little
Wolves of Wall Street wannabes um and
they promote these stocks and the stocks
go from you know 2 cents up to a dollar
a share 50 times your money then they
come crashing down just as fast when the
promotion ends it's not an exact science
but that's the gist of it and is there
liquidity in the market yeah so this is
the thing so I also had a $500,000 loss
along the way on my way to making five
plus million um and I learned to stay
away from illiquid penny stocks I
believed in the company I believed in
the technology I was actually right
about the technology they invented
prints at home ticketing but but it
doesn't matter about the product the
company had big debts and I couldn't get
out of my position cuz it was a liquid
so now I stick to the most volatile most
liquid stocks they trade 5 10 20
sometimes 50 million shares in a day and
so what what does your day look like
what's it name a time zone you tell me
because I'm trading in Asia and I'm
trading at night and just trying to
sleep during the day um in Europe it's
fantastic I go to Italy every summer
I've been very fortunate uh to go to
Positano Italy I don't know if you've
been there on the Amalfi Coast you
should go beautiful food and the people
it's amazing so the US Stock Market
which is what I trade I don't trade
international um the US Stock Market
opens around 330 um in the afternoon so
I can sleep till noon have a nice little
lunch trade from usually it's the first
hour of the trading day where there's
volatility so like 3:30 to 4:30 p.m. um
then I go out have fun you know go to
the beach uh and come back around 900 or
10 p.m. for the last hour of trading at
night and then go out for dinner and
then I go out to a club that's my that's
my life they so this style of trading
you're doing you need an hour the way
you're doing it with your own account
you need an hour in the the morning and
an hour yeah roughly I mean sometimes
there's no trades like today I didn't
make a trade um there's not always a
trade because there's not always a hot
penny stock so for me I need some you
know pump going on I need like a hot
Trend like Bitcoin or weed right now
there's no clear hot Trend what's been
happening lately is there is a lot of
short sellers in penny stocks and they
short too aggressively they because most
penny stocks fail eventually but they
don't really iiz that these penny stocks
can go very high um you know Insanity
can last longer than they can last in
their short position so a lot of these
penny stocks are going from 2 to 20 2 to
50 in a few days um and it's been a
crazy few weeks so the short squeezes
have been the main Trend so is that
something that you watch as short
positions in yeah 100% um I'm always
looking for the next big short squeeze
and similar companies move in similar um
directions you know there was a company
SC um and they bought another company
and the stock sky rocket it went from 2
to 27 in 2 days the next day BMI which
is another low price stock was trading
around two and they acquired a company
so very similar news and it traded in a
similar fashion so I missed sces
completely because I was just like this
is crazy this isn't you know I'm scared
but the second time I was like wait a
minute this could be a trend so I bought
the stock it was already up to like $250
$2.50 a share from like 150 so was
already up like 75% bought it at 250
sold it at 320 the same day like a few
hours later um I think I made like 20%
right that was pretty good and by Day
end it was up to 11 so I sold it too
soon but if I can make 20% that's fine I
said out there during their presentation
that I'm like I I take singles I'm like
the Jewish icho if you like baseball I
don't go for home runs they well in a
bunch of consistent singles yeah singles
add up so my average gain is less than
$22,000 but it's added up to over 5
million again and again because I cut my
losses quickly when I'm wrong which is
roughly a third of the time I lose 1 2
3% % but when I'm right I make 7 8 9 10
15% so when you have students and and
they watch you trade do they just mirror
your trades or I don't want anybody to
follow my trades so for me the best
thing is that I do watch list and I do
video lessons so I say like I'm watching
this stock ahead of time um I trade with
a small account I go back to $122,000
every year because I don't want to like
you know trade with a big account for me
I trade like my students trade so they
have like 12,000 5,000 $20,000 accounts
so I put my myself in the mindset of a
student and I say okay how do I make you
know $500 I say $500 a day keeps the
real job away um so I do that and the
cool thing is most of my students are
already in the stock like they already
know my strategy because I have DVDs I
have video lessons so it's the same
patterns this isn't like some rocket
science penny stocks aren't that
complicated so I I didn't know so you
start every year over a reset and with
$122,000 in your account that's why I'm
pretty much stuck at 5 million because
every now and then I make some money but
like it only adds up to to like1
$200,000 in a year so compared to every
other Trader who's trying to trade with
as much money as possible my Niche is
smaller so I trade with a small account
for me it's teaching the process and I
donate all my profits to charity that's
how I built my charity foundation and
build all these schools that's just
spectacular that's good so it's a little
different than what I thought I thought
I was going to be a big hedge fund
manager and you know manage billions but
my Niche is very small like you cannot
trade these penny stock moves with you
know billions of dollars you there's not
enough liquidity for that so you're not
really it like are you're not looking at
the fundamentals of a company
fundamentals that's the beautiful thing
with penny stocks there's no
fundamentals everyone's like oh what's
the valuation what's this technology we
know that 99 probably 99.9% of these
penny stocks are going to fail so even
if they do have fundamentals they're
probably just stacking their accounting
to look good um even when they do have
some revenues or profits I mean not all
of them are totally worthless but they
have hype and they're just trying to get
their stock price up so they can do a
financing in order to last longer so
penny stocks there's two reasons to have
a penny stock either the Insiders are
trying to sell in the inflated price a
pump and dump or they might raise a
financing so like a penny stock might go
from like let's say $2 to $7 and they'll
do a financing at $4 a share but they
couldn't do the $4 a Shar financing when
it was at two so they in increased the
price with like seven press releases
over eight days hype it up with all
these new contracts whether they come to
fruition or not they got their stock up
they raised 5 million and then they
gradually you know take the $5 million
in employment salaries over the next few
years as they drain the company and it
goes to Oblivion so it's a very sad
cynical little I say uh expect the worst
out of everybody and you won't be
disappointed it's I was going to say
it's a little bit of a cynical view for
such a happy guy who's having such fun I
just you have to realize the odds you
know again penny stocks are hated
because so many people fall for their
scams they fall for their stories oh we
just found this gold in Peru oh we have
this cancer vaccine and they just
they're just wrong they're every single
time they're wrong so I don't mind the
hype I respect it because that's part of
the niche there's always going to be
another small company and another hot
product but it just never works so who
are the people that are
buying these shares who are like I mean
it's like the people who go to
racetracks and they bet on the 50 to1
you know horses and every now and then a
50 to1 horse wins actually probably more
than a penny stock wins if you look at
the odds um they don't have a lot of
money they're desperate the stock is
trading at 5 cents a share it's being
pitched to them in an email or maybe
their friend is giving them a tip they
don't know much about Finance they look
at it like a lotto ticket um sometimes
they buy 10 penny stocks and they're
like well one of them has to hit and
then sometimes it does and they learn
the wrong lessons so for me I don't
believe in any companies anymore like I
said I had a $500,000 loss once upon a
time I did believe in the technology I
learned the hard way but like I said
also I was actually right about the
technology but the company went out of
business uh they had too many debts the
CEO who looked me in the eye and said
that this company is good don't worry he
put it into bankruptcy he actually
personally bought the company in
bankruptcy somehow held on to all the
contracts for the print at home uh
technology print at home ticketing and
the stock later went up uh as all the
original shareholders like me were wiped
out and he sold it for the equivalent of
$80 million so I actually would have
made like 10 15 million but it was the
wrong time and I'm thankful for that
lesson because that would have been a
bad 10 or 15 million cuz then I would
have been like oh I know everything you
know I was batting a th000 then a
$500,000 loss for someone like me you
know when I was young and I was on a TV
show um it really knocked the the wind
out of my sales which was great it was
tough in the meantime but it was it's
beautiful everybody needs that I I had
one of my kids when he was 10 um we were
in a line for a buffet in Las Vegas and
all the slot machines are there and he
begged for uh he wanted his $5 that his
mom had in her purse for him he wanted
put his $5 in the slot machine and she's
like no you're not going to we're not
going to let you do that and he's you
know please please and I said let him do
it this will be good for but he won a
th000 bucks terrible lesson terrible
terrible lesson everybody needs a
failure story to reset the clock for
what reality is that's why my parents
gave me my 12,000 they thought that I
would lose it all they're like give the
kid the 12,000 he'll learn the value of
a dollar and I screwed it all up by
making 100 Grand and 700 Grand then I
was
the uh well I think you did better with
the lesson of course the lesson ended up
costing you 500,000 not 12,000 but you
were in a place to lose it but it was
amazing and you know I lost I was
running a hedge fund at the time I lost
roughly a third of my hedge fund in one
year um I was on the TV show Wall Street
Warriors at the time so all the Press
was circulating being like Oh Tim syes
lost you know they thought that I blew
up first of all which wasn't true but
back then you couldn't show your hedge
fund numbers publicly I was like I did
not lose everything I lost 30% but I
couldn't say it publicly I was like damn
these laws um now you can say it but
they equated it because the TV show was
airing even though it was like six
months ago and they thought that my loss
happened because I was on TV so all the
Press said Tim syes is on TV he got too
cocky and he has a loss and I'm like I
was in this position long before the TV
show yes it was a mistake but it was an
IL liquid so I I tried to go into like
the nuances and the Press weren't having
it so I I have all these embarrassing uh
you know headlines like uh when I
started teaching it said failed hedge
fund man tries again on the internet
that was Reuters I had a 4our talk with
her and she didn't understand wouldn't
have been a good headline the New York
yeah the New York Post said part's over
for a hedge fund King I was like I'm a
hedge fund I had $3 million in my hedge
fund I wasn't exactly a king but it was
like the most popular article on page
six for like a month so I was up with
the TV show and I was down with the
press and that was actually the best
lesson because it really humbled me more
than just the money but the bad press
really like hit home for me I was in my
early 20s and I was a you dumb kid
the and best lesson amazing I am so
thankful for it it was a rough few
months but it made me you know recognize
how little information was out there
because I was trying to explain what an
illiquid penny stock was no one even
understood they're like what is this
technical talk what's IL liquidity and I
was like H so I was like let me just
teach it let me just get into that and
that's what made me get into teaching I
think to the
novice it's very difficult to con CE
that the company can be doing one thing
and the stock can be doing something
completely these are two different
markets two different things and and
especially did you get down these lower
price stocks that there's you know even
less of a relationship but there's a
whole movie you know Sirus satellite
radio right everyone uses it there's a
movie made by investors in serus
satellite radio who claim that their
stock wasn't doing well because there's
a whole conspiracy of short sellers
holding it down and they're trying to
make the case everyone uses serious
satellite radio this should be a blue
chip company this should be a blue chip
stock and they interview like all these
different investors and yet all they had
to do was look at the balance sheet and
look that they acquired all their growth
they acquired all their customers
through debt the company was actually
hugely overvalued even though was a low
price stock and the stock really I mean
it's done decently but it it's not a
blue chip stock and no matter how
popular the product is they paid for it
with too much debt so their whole
company is screwed so how do you when
you're researching these stocks I got to
assume they're are they traded are they
NASDAQ stocks NASDAQ OTC bulling board
but I I mean you can look through their
o their SEC filings on otcmarkets.com um
so you can see it and I have a whole DVD
on learn to read SEC filings and you can
see red flags I mean the companies say
that they're pretty much failing they're
like we do not have enough cash to last
for more than six months our accountant
says that we are at Great risk of going
bankrupt like they say this in black and
white but people don't read the 40 50 60
70 page SEC filings people read the one
or two page press releases saying we
found gold in Peru so there's two
different sets of data and the majority
of people who invest in penny stocks
don't even know about the SEC filings
now I I'm way out of date but there used
to be rules that made it difficult to
invest in stocks that were under $5 that
were easy online discount brokers have
allowed anything uh you know now Brokers
are going commission free so there's
even more of a free-for-all for these
low price stocks and they don't have a
know your customer no they don't care
wow so this really is the wild gam you
know like this is the 1840s gold rush I
remember there used to be brokerage
firms that specialized in penny stocks
and the SEC pretty much systematically
eliminated the I mean they're still
broke they're still specialized Brokers
I use ER trade and interactive brokers
two big multi-billion dollar Brokers
they they work well you know Robin Hood
is a new upstart uh broker and you can
trade penny stocks there and you don't
even need more than like $50 to open an
account there so it's very bottom of the
barrel investing in trading and most of
these newbies just lose everything and
then they just hate penny stocks not
because penny stocks are bad but just
because they don't know the rules and
they don't know the rules of the game so
that's why I teach so this is brand I
mean I love I love the this you cut out
for yourself it's um again I don't think
I would call it investing it's trading
it's trading 100% I call my students
degenerate gamblers and I'm a degenerate
Gambler too I'm like the alcoholic
bartender serving up drinks but I put
rules in place so that I recognize my
own issues I'm a degenerate Trader part
of the reason why I travel so much is
not just to build schools and because I
love travel but because it's tough for
me to trade from Bali the Wi-Fi as you
know is not that great the time zone is
not that great so that prevents me from
overtrading because there's so many
different penny stocks in play but I
need to be patient enough to wait for
all my indicators to line up like I only
want to buy penny stocks that are
hitting new highs with enough volume
with a news Catalyst ideally in a hot
sector and ideally the overall Market
Market is in a bull market too so if I
have all those indicators lined up the
odds of success are greater but if I'm
only buying a penny stock that has no
history of spiking and they only have
like one great press release it's
probably not going to spike that much so
I need multiple indicators so how long
would does it take your students to
become competent at what you're doing
yeah so this is a long time so my top
student Tim gratani um has turned 1500
of his own money now into 8.7 million in
seven years which is awesome he's done
you know made nearly double what I've
made in half the time cuz he's a
superstar and he's really dedicated I
took him to the males and I was trying
to get him drunk and he wouldn't even
drink he was like on his laptop in the
middle of the night he's dedicated um
but he made nothing his first nine
months and he was studying at home he
was living at home uh working at like
State Farm during the day and you you
know the penny stock Niche is so weird
right a lot of the lessons are
counterintuitive I think of myself as a
retired Trader and I only come out of
retirement when there's a play that's
good enough like what kind of rule is
that but it actually works so 9 to 12
months is just to like really break even
and learn uh the ins and outs and you
have to see examples of good stocks bad
stocks and that's in a hot market so if
there's no hot Market it really takes 12
or 18 months and a lot of people don't
want to have that perspective that's why
I like teaching this because everyone
wants quick money just like the slot
machines right penny stocks are so cheap
I don't care about your rules I don't
care about your patterns just give me
the money and sometimes in a hot sector
like with you know weed stocks or CBD
stocks or Bitcoin stocks my rules didn't
matter you could buy any penny stock in
that sector when they were spiking and
they would go up 500% so I had a lot of
my students being like screw your rules
PES I just made 500% and then when the
sector ended they lost it all yeah and
what causes these sectors for pot stocks
for for
Bitcoin all of these Suddenly at once
all the companies in the pot stock were
were going up I mean it's it's a
self-fulfilling you know prophecy and
it's also just dumb Lemmings who just
you know pile on to each other and like
oh I'm buying this I'm buying this
obviously there were reasons behind like
the pot stock spiked because of
legislation that was making it more and
more legal in more States um Bitcoin
spiked you know frankly just because it
was like a Mania and everyone got all
excited and now it's come down a little
bit um but it's still up you know we're
at 9,000 right now on bitcoin and it was
at you know under 30 like a few years
ago so it's still holding the majority
of it gains even though it's down from
20,000 um my niche doesn't have hedge
funds it doesn't have Quant Traders it
doesn't have a lot of big money so it's
really just individual investor optimism
um and they get really excited very
quickly even though there's no real hope
in the future they don't really think
about the future they're just they're
gamblers you know well I love that you
know there are professional gamblers who
make a great living being professional
gamblers you can be meticulous in and
out of the herd you know like the herd
isn't smart right so a lot of my best
trades are based on informational
inefficiencies I'll tell you my first
$100,000 profit um in college freshman
year in college I bought the stock it
was already up from 5 to 17 this was 20
years ago but the pattern still works um
5 to 17 in a few days they had this
technology that theoretically could um
take the fuzziness out of your cell
phones right like cell phones were very
fuzzy they had a whole scientific
approach and the stock was spiking and
on Friday they said we're going to be on
TV on Sunday we've been interviewed it's
a great interview it's going to finally
air on Sunday they announced it on
Friday so I said wow this is this is
going to be big news over the weekend
back then there were no expose so and
back then I didn't have my big loss yet
so I was betting too much at that time I
was worth about a quarter of a million I
bought 10,000 shares at 17 so I put in
$1 170,000 of my $250,000 like an idiot
like a newbie idiot that I was but back
then there were no expose it was a
positive interview the stock gapped up
on Monday um there was no pre-market
trading back then so I thought that it
would Gap up to like 20 I could make
like 30 grand it gapped up to 27 28 29
and I made 120 Grand and I ran around
the you know whole quad just screaming
and I sold two soon an hour later was
over 40 so I didn't per perfectly like
adjust to the hype but I still locked in
my biggest gain ever so what are some
more of your rules that you've because I
like these lessons you learn because
these are from The Real World this is
not Academia this is so what are some
more of your rules that guide you in
your yeah I mean I really like weekend
plays so that's why I have like a
newsletter where you know if a stock has
good news on Friday with penny stocks
because the whole world hates on them
they don't really see the news until
Saturday Sunday Monday they put in their
buy orders the buy orders stack up on
Monday you have a gap up you can sell
them to the late comers um sometimes
it's not even day two I'll tell you one
more example Carl icon you know big
investor invested in this little penny
stock vltc um on the news of his
investment it went from one to two I
bought it at two was already up 100% on
the day my whole chat room is like why
are you buying a stock up 100% like it's
going to go down I was like no Carl icon
just vetted this like he can invest in
any company he wants and he basically
just gave his seal of approval for this
little crappy penny stock um next day I
sold it like in the threes I made my 20
30 50% um on different positions like
just a few thousand dollars very small
position two weeks later it was at 20
plus two another two more weeks it was
bankrupt or back down to like nearly
zero so the media caught on I think on
day seven day eight and they said look
at this stock that's spiking on Carl
icon so there's an informational
inefficiency with what I do where even
if a company has the best news because
everyone hates on penny stocks you don't
see it for the next few days but it's
not an exact science so it might not
Spike on day two exact sometimes it
spikes on day eight and I can give you
20 examples where it spiked on day eight
for whatever reason so how many trades
will you do in the course of a week or a
month um I mean usually like three
trades per week so you know roughly 10
trades per month there's not much cuz I
wait for all the indicators I need to
wait for the news and a good setup but
different months are different you know
like when Bitcoin was exploding I would
do five trades a day because there were
so many plays um bitcoin's not exploding
I mean sometimes there's no trades for
three or four days usually there's one
trade per week but that's that's like
bare minimum and are you always long do
do you ever short no I I mean I made my
first million going long I made my
second million shorting like in 2002
there were no more penny stock breakouts
the year 2000 I made 700,000 Plus for
the year but I made it all in the first
four months the last eight months of the
year I lost $10,000 when I did not know
Short Selling so the penny stock
breakouts dried up and it forced me to
learn shorting right now I'm going
mostly long because the short squeezes
are insane it's not good risk reward but
if there's a pump and dump that's going
to crash I will gladly short it there's
just usually not a lot of shares to
short when there are shares to short um
it usually spikes even more so you have
to risk a little pain it's not it's not
as easy as it was in the beginning and
so how do how do you do the rese how do
you find out there's a big shorts
position in the stock um I mean you just
look on social media these days the
beautiful thing is like you know if
you're a short seller you're usually
telling everybody because you want
everybody else to know this is a bad
company and you can just look and you
see like 50 of the biggest short Sellers
and they're so stupid but it's like you
know how do you tell if someone's vegan
they'll tell you how do you how do you
tell if someone's a short seller they'll
tell you they're so proud of it they
think that they're so Noble and mighty
and everyone else is wrong so that's not
going to change anytime soon yeah how do
you tell if somebody's they'll tell you
how do you tell if they have a rescue
dog yeah 100% you'll know everything
it's the same thing with shorting penny
stocks there's a lot of traders who are
like I will never buy a penny stock and
the crazy thing is that some of the
worst fundamentally flawed companies
become the biggest spikers when so many
shorts are involved there's a penny
stock drys dry ships right and their
shipping company terrible fundamentals
huge debts like not a good business
model and the stock started spiking from
I think like five to like eight dollars
a share on some positive press releases
and some positive industry news and all
the shorts were like this doesn't
deserve to go from 5 to8 we're shorting
it it doesn't even deserve to go to Five
it's fundamentally worthless and they
went crazy and it went 8 10 12 14 and
the shorts are going crazy on social
media being like this is not legitimate
this does not value it it goes from 5 to
120 in 5 days wow so many short sellers
I know were wiped out shorting it they
went all in at 40 50 60 saying this is
madness but it went up to 120 it was
actually halted by the SEC pre-market at
120 it probably would have hit 200 that
day if it hadn't been halted then it
crashed and eventually was worthless so
it looks like to me that you've uh it's
funny it's I I can almost Envision
somebody managed to walk through a
shooting gallery with bullets flying all
around them and I'm like the Matrix I
can then different ways right so what is
but I get hit every now and then too as
well you should you know it's you're in
a risky Place can't but I have a lot of
1 2 3 4% losses so a lot of the time
even when I short like a pump and dump
there's all these penny stock promoters
who absolutely hate me cuz I teach this
stuff openly right before me no one even
really knew that you could short sell
penny stocks when I was on my TV show
Wall Street Warriors I was shorting
penny stocks on TV it became a hit and I
would get daily emails saying my broker
says you can't short sell penny stocks
what you're doing is illegal Brokers
would say that it's illegal because they
couldn't find shares to short and they
didn't want to look like the crappy
Brokers that they were so they told
their clients they lied to them no you
can't short sell penny stocks so that's
what got me into education I was like my
blood boiled it wasn't even about making
money it wasn't even a business I was
just like of course you can short sell
penny stocks and I was using eade at the
time like I didn't have you didn't need
like a specialized broker um so it's
just about getting good information out
there and understanding that you know
you're not perfect um there's no magic
formula to getting rich but more times
than not if you learn the patterns you
can make money that's what I do so what
do you see coming up next or do you you
what what's drawing your attention for
the next 12 months whatever happens
happens like people ask me what's the
Dow going to do what's the next hot
sector I have no idea I learn to react
to PR price action I don't try to
predict it so everyone's like what
should I put my money in right now and I
say invest in yourself right what should
I study right now study the past like I
wait for the setup and then if the setup
is there I'll tell you another story I
actually said this outside um I do an
annual conference every year um and I
had 600 students at my Orlando
conference is a three-day conference
zero trades there were no good trades
we're sitting there for three days
everyone's like you know I'm teaching
these rules I'm like you got to have
patience you gotta have everyone's like
yeah you gotta have patience but they're
traveling I mean they're flying in from
all over the world right there's a
little disappointment I can tell because
even if it was a bad trade they just
want to see me trade live and I was like
there's no good trades literally some
people had already left going into the
last break um it was like 3:15 3:30 p.m.
and I have this all in video it's
actually pretty fun I have to put it on
YouTube um people left they said thank
you for the conference you know kind of
dejected and I was like oh I wish there
was a play but I I can't course a play
to happen then do you know Dan Bill
areion on Instagram so he has nearly 30
million followers um but he also
probably has like 20 million followers
who can't officially follow him but
they're like watching what he does but
their girl their girlfriends and wives
would be angry if they followed him
right so he has a massive audience in
around 3:15 p.m. Eastern maybe 3:20 p.m.
Eastern he put on his story he has a
weed company bzf is his ticker and he
put it on his story and he's like you
know my my company now has a US symbol
and the stock immediately spiked from
like a120 to $140
as some people bought because they
didn't know that he had a weed company
they didn't know the ticker and he said
you know he gave like a disclaimer like
check with your broker whatever but
people had found out about it for the
first time and I had said this in a
webinar years ago I was like if Dan Bill
Arion ever mentions his ticker to his
followers the stock is going to spike
just because of the sheer amount of
followers um so the stock spiked from a
buck 20 to a buck 40 in the last 20 30
minutes of my conference and I'm up on
stage and I'm like literally I'm just
going down to my list of big percent
gers this is how I find the stocks
anything that's up 20 20 30 40% on the
day and then I go back and look at the
news so I see 20 30 40% some winners but
no exciting news then I see bzf and
literally we have this on video and I'm
like what did Bill zarion say something
and I check my phone and I'm like oh my
God he mentioned it right and so are you
on Instagram I am so you know like their
story lasts 24 hours right so he didn't
do a post he put it in his story but he
put it around 3:15 p.m. 3:20 p.m.
Eastern um so the story lasts 24 hours
but you only had to 40-minute window to
buy the stock otherwise you're going to
see it when the Stock Market opens the
next day so most of his followers
they're not like stock market efficient
Autos they're not meticulous they're not
even checking his story right away
especially if you don't follow him this
is the thing if you follow somebody you
see it but there's a lot of people who
unofficially follow him so they might
check in especially at night right they
want to see his girl so like at 10 p.m.
I'm sure his traffic spikes or like at
midnight guys check his like feed like
what's Dan up to today stock market is
closing at 10: p.m. or 12 or 12:00 a.m.
right so I bought the stock it was
already up from a buck 20 to a buck 40 I
got it on a little dip at a buck 30 it
closed at a buck 40 and I was like I
just want to Gap up to a buck 50 or a
buck 60 I think people are going to see
it overnight and they're going to put in
their buy orders no different than my
first $100,000 game and I I was happy
that it was like my perfect kind of play
I had three students up on stage and
they're like that's your kind of
catalyst right where it's like an
informational inefficiency and all I
wanted was like a 10 or 20 cent Gap up
and then I would sell into that I had
like 9,000 right um instead the stock
gaps up to two and I sell immediately
I'm like I made 40% every one of you saw
that yes right seven minutes later after
I sell it at two the stock is at four
bucks a share cu the market maker is
just pillaged right like I guarantee you
that his followers are not financially
meticulous so they use Market orders I
always use limit orders because I I
never want to chase a stock too much but
I guarantee you most of his people
didn't even know the difference between
a market order and a limit order so they
probably put in buy $10,000 shares of
Bill arean stock and thinking oh I'll
get it at two right $20,000 meanwhile
the market makers see all the buy orders
and they just take advantage of them and
somebody who tried to buy 10,000 shares
at two probably bought it at four and
now they're down from four the stock is
down to $160 and that person is like I
hate penny stocks even though they just
didn't know the rules of the game
meanwhile me and all my students who
know the rules of the game sold ahead so
and I'm sure most people know but
explain the difference between a market
order and a limit order yeah so a market
order means you can buy the stock or
sell the stock at any price whatever the
market will Bear right it's like going
to grocery store and you really want
milk and you're like I'll pay whatever
for a gallon of milk even though a
gallon milk should be like three four $5
right that's it but you want milk so
much and you just gave the grocery store
okay I'll charge you $100 and you said
sold because you want the milk so bad
and you're just paying what the market
will give you and the grosser sets the
market it's the stupidest thing ever
never use Market orders for any stock no
company is worth the unlimited risk that
it comes with normally you'll be okay
because the market is usually rational
but in this case with Dan bilzerian's
company the market was not rational I
guarantee you that probably half maybe
even more than half of the orders were
Market orders and that's what drove the
price up from two to four in seven
minutes so I made my 40% but I missed
out on the extra 100% I love it and a
limit price is you just specify so if
you want to buy 10,000 shares at two you
put a limit at $2 a share and if the
stock goes past it you don't get
executed and that's fine I've missed a
lot of stocks uh run ups and rund Downs
when I use a limit order but I don't
need to be in a stock that bad no stock
is worth unlimited risk but so a lot of
what you're doing is mindset you have
have manipulated your thinking where
instead of being upset oh I could have
if I'd have held on longer that could
really Ru somebody in this kind of
trading if they can't you know be happy
with you know walking away with the
percentage that they set yeah 100%
there's fomo all the time I mean I can't
tell you how many of my students like
even when I made my 40% on the bill Aran
stock and I'm like perfect trade and
they're like what do you mean perfect
trade you missed out on 100% I'm like I
don't care I I'm used to that if I make
40% that's like the upper level of what
I make do you ever play ski ball you
know ski ball you try and shoot it up
and you make 10 20 30 40 and then
there's two hundreds so newbies would go
for the hundreds on the the top corners
and it's so hard I just go straight up
whether I hit 50 40 30 I'm happy and
they all add up that's that's what it is
that I literally have a whole video
Lesson on ski ball yep that's what it is
so I'm happy with I'm very happy with
40% but newbies they want home runs
that's they see stars in their eyes they
see money because they're you know they
see my millions of dollars like I post
my pictures of like my cars and my trips
and they're like oh my God that's going
to cost a lot of money but what they
don't see is that it's lots of small
gains meticulously added up over time
and lots of small losses well I love the
way you have uh taken what um is really
the Bottom Rung of the ladder and made a
a really brilliant career out of I'm a
coward Trader I have a whole DVD where I
say I'm a castrated choir boy and I talk
like this this is how I trade this is
how a cast traded choir boy talks I
don't know any but I feel like that's
how they would talk and I talk like that
for hours and people are like what are
you are you losing your mind but I I
need people to understand that the stock
market is dangerous trading is dangerous
and penny stocks are extra dangerous and
I'm short selling day trading and Penny
stocking the three most dangerous things
together but I trade it in a very
conservative manner with some really
good rules that came harder time tested
rules that's what it comes down to so a
lot of newbies ignore my rules R and
they're Gunslingers and they might make
some profits faster than I do but I win
more in the long run I can't tell you
how many Gunslingers I've ignored my
rules and they've made a lot and they're
like syes you're a dinosaur adapt to the
you know when the weed stocks were
spiking adapt to the market I'm like
these are my rules I've learned them
over 20 years in good markets and bad
markets you go do your thing and then
they get crushed and they get very
introspective on Twitter um and I don't
like like saying I Told You So this
isn't about I told you so it's just
rules and you either learn them the hard
way or you learn them through me or
maybe it's a combination I don't know
everything but I know rules because
frankly I've been doing this for long
enough well it's almost like um um Zig
Ziggler talked about the cross-side
discus thrower he said you know he
didn't set any records but he did keep
the crowd alert the one thing about you
may not set trading Day Records but I
can see how you keep the crowd alert
it's funny when I'm on these panels and
like I I've only made $5 million over
you know 20 plus years mind you I'm
trading with a small account like
teaching so I've kind of shot myself in
the foot for Big trading gains over the
past 10 years but that's fine um but
they're literally laughing at me cuz
some Traders make 5 million in a day but
for me I'm teaching people like most of
my students have a few thousand dollars
to their name and if you try to trade
with a big money strategy and Penny
you'll get destroyed so my strategy is
tailored for people with small accounts
that pretty much all of Wall Street
forgets and the whole world forgets and
they laugh at me like I've been on
panels before and I said this outside
like I've been on panels where I made
$350 in a day and I was like oh I just
made 350 and literally the panels are
like billionaire Traders and like
billionaire investors and they're like
you only made 350,000 today and like
they think that's small and I was like
no I made $350 today and the crowd is
laughing I did I said this in Vancouver
and I was like they're like 300 like my
lunch was more than that I'm like well
that's a good lunch you know so there's
a whole um kind of opportunity I think
where you have all these Wall Street
snobs and Elite people where they forget
that there's a lot of opportunity with
the small market and all the small
Market people most people who trade
penny stocks are either promoters or
scammers or people who believe in these
companies so there's a lot of
opportunity for somebody who's just
meticulous and kind of Ruthless um in
disciplined in this Niche full of idiots
like I say it's like kind of like
playing like basketball against a
right like I'm not that great at
basketball but if you place a in
front of me I'm just going to block him
all day long well $500 a day keeps the
job away yes keeps the real job away
it's still a job but it's not a real job
I'm trading from a beach in Bali you
know I'm I'm in Italy like I can trade
from anywhere so it is a job I don't
want people to think oh money's just
going to fall from the sky but it's not
a real job like I don't have to commute
I don't have to stay in the office I
don't even own a suit if you see me
wearing this outfit because this is like
my fanciest outfit that I have so I keep
wearing it over and over again to any
fancy thing literally this photo of me
outside has the same exact sweater and I
was like does anybody notice so I'm
going to call myself out on that yeah
we'll have to get some b roll in that so
we can cut do it it's fun so Tim thank
you this has been just terrific what a
what a pleasure to get to know you
thanks for having me
[Music]
man the thing that strikes me about the
stories we just heard from Dean Nomi and
Tim is that fear has no place in what
they do an easy Takeaway on your path to
finding your wealth breakthrough is to
educate yourself to the point that fear
melts away away that makes for better
decision- making and an easier path to
success I really encourage you to share
this episode with your friends and
family anyone in your life who needs to
see this critical information you could
be responsible for not only transforming
your own life with what you see in
wealth breakthroughs you could also do
the same for someone else share this
episode with everyone you know and we'll
see you next time for episode
hi there Patrick gentempo again your
episode 2 bonus interview comes to you
from Dave Blanchard remember this number
$619 that's how much a 111 page book you
can get on Amazon costs Dave will tell
you all about it this 52-year-old book
changed Dave's life forever he'll also
show you how the wrong types of debt are
keeping your dreams at a distance and
how there's more to a truly fulfilled
life than just having piles and piles of
money ladies and gentlemen here's Dave
[Music]
Blancher Dave I'm a big fan and really
excited to have this interview so uh
thank you for taking the time to sit
with us thank you my pleasure so let's
talk about your background and kind of
how you got involved ining the kind of
work you do today okay short version
yeah it does not to be that short after
school started the financial services
business MH and this is part of our
discussion about wealth creation if I'm
going to sell insurance I'm going to
sell it to people who need a lot of it
right makes sense right so I specialize
with doctors right uh pretty soon
doctors needed a whole lot more than
insurance they needed to set up in
practice they need leas hold
improvements they needed staff they need
to train they need a practice management
right and within a few years it was the
largest practice management consulting
firm south of Los Angeles in San Diego
MH and I'm investing in real estate
privately cuz I figure that's a pretty
good investment right right and all of a
sudden the doctors is saying I heard
about that apartment you did can I get
involved in the next One MH so we
started having more of them get involved
in the real estate and pretty soon I
sold off the practice and we were just
developing real estate right then 1986
came tax reform act by 1989 right we
were building our last $5.4 million
project we sold for 5.3 million not good
business deal didn't work really well
you know a million dollars down million
dollar second within 3 years the market
had dropped even lower they just reneged
on the loan that fell apart wow I was
the corporate guarantor of all the lines
of credit oo ooh yeah a million dollars
wow and so when the company wasn't able
to pay that they visited me yeah so I
would spend the next 10 years paying it
back wow and that really was formative
now I could have filed bankruptcy I was
just ask I I don't want to say to
someone don't because sometimes it's
really the right thing to do but I had
some lessons to learn MH so I learned
them very thoroughly and during that
process uh had a chance to read OG
Mandino's book The Greatest salesman in
the world and it was like it's like
putting on an old shoe you know it's
really comfortable yeah and I remember
saying he's got the same
teacher he's got the same
teacher so that developed into meeting
the mandino family MH next thing you
know I'm writing the feature film script
for one of a Mandino's books wow and in
January of 2000 Betty calls me I'm
shooting some commercials for CNBC in
New York mhm we get off early and we
take the crew down to get into The Lion
King we're standing in the cancellation
line right January 2000 world hasn't
come to an end and uh Betty called me
and she said Dave the rights to the
greatest salesman of the world are not
being
renewed would you be
interested of course I said this is a
rhetorical question right she said no
I'm very serious okay so over the next
hour we talked with the publisher in
Florida her attorney in New York our
attorney in Los Angeles and by the time
we got down we worked out the framework
for me to come home leave the film
business and take over the ogmandino
brand name the family Jewel the greatest
salesman in the world 10 Scrolls wow and
begin to build a training company mhm
and good news for everyone we're
scripting the Netflix series oh really
yes um which is very exciting a 10art
episode of the greatest salesman in the
world to make a movie out of that is
really hard to do so we're going to do
it in episodes I love it so we're very
excited about that so everything's
finally after 20 years is when someone
says you know gosh I wish I was in your
shoes and I I'm not sure you want to
walk that path if you do that's cool cuz
show you how to do that yeah there's
theal that is you some people think uh
you know they're they're born on third
base and think they hit a triple yeah
yeah they didn't know what it was to
strike out it bad a few times Marl Osman
said that to me once he said someone
said gosh I wish I had your success and
I said yeah it was an overnight 16year
success so fill in one gap for me okay
here you where real estate crashed you
had a guaranteed a loan you had to pay
off that you decided that you're going
to feel the pain and paying it off just
to learn something as compared to
bankrupting next thing I know you're in
the film business so how did where's the
Gap what happened in there real estate
business yeah I want to do something
meaningful yeah so I produced a music
video on teenage drinking and driving
wow okay and next thing you know it's on
television and it's in 30,000 schools I
mean oh that was fun let's do another
one yeah so we did one on acquaintance
rape uh that wasn't quite as popular cuz
we did it special Iz in college campuses
but when we were doing the premiere of
that film right in the middle of the
show and we could hear a boy just burst
into tears and the therapist grabbed me
said follow me and we went outside he
worked his way out of the audience and
outside and it turned out he'd been a
victim of child abuse when he was 12 oh
wow and they prosecuted the man he'd
gone to jail for it but his father said
to him okay it's done we're going to
talk about ever again wow until that
moment in time wow okay I left that and
I said we have to do the quintessential
film on Child Abuse
Prevention so a buddy of mine put in
265,000 I put in 265,000 and we heard
Manuel Lewis Webster Tiffany Brett from
Small Wonder that was a great show back
then little robot girl I remember Gordon
jump WKRP in Cincinnati and we did the
quintessential series on emotional
physical and sexual child abuse and the
US military bought one for every
Department of Defense School worldwide
wow Every Family Services Unit worldwide
and another 40,000 schools in Canada New
Zealand Australia United States bought
it wow well that is all happening before
the world fell apart mhm and I'm
going you know I kind of like making
films so when I'm going to be paying
back a million dollars in debt and I
really am I mean we were poorer than
Church mice M it was scary yeah we sold
our favorite Eagle statue and fruitwood
inlaid grandfather clock out of the back
of the truck to the guy buying our new
house our old house excuse me and and as
we were moving and here we were just
about pennes and so I said I'm going to
become a writer and director just as an
advocation I'm going to actually do this
right yeah it's like a sure thing well I
was able to do it before I was paying
for it so I got to write and direct it
you know my my writing D directing debut
was the first one I ever did you know
it's one of those kind of things and so
I started writing and a good friend Rick
Larsson uh who's now the the president
of Southerland Institute he was running
a a production facility he called me one
day and he said I've been looking for
you I remembered your educational films
I've got a client that needs a script
written and I need a little bit of your
flare would you consider writing it I
said sure check check book you know zero
Z yeah absolutely I'll be happy to write
it so I poured my heart into the script
and that turned into
200 TV commercials wow uh five feature
film scripts wow uh several tv specials
the Goodman family special on CBS Etc
quite a fun career that's what led to me
writing a Mandino's script for the
Christ commission that led us to Betty
asking if I'd be interested in the movie
rights the greatest salesman in the
world that led to building an entire
company around those principles right
and here we are today so something very
interesting here is that these varying
call business activities yes careers um
are not really that related you're the
common denominator but they don't seem
like hey you know there's a particular
skill set that you have and that's you
know that's what you do for decades of
your life you kind of like did many
different things and figured out how to
succeed at it um what's the common
denominator two okay
one tremendous passion for it when you
have passion you work without counting
the cost or tracking the time you do
whatever it takes to figure it out right
and two is just an undying work ethic
which I thank my father for greatest
gift he gave me was it was the work work
ethic yeah so talk to me then because I
know you also write books yes right so
what inspired you to write books instead
of movie scripts uh or TV commercials
and uh what's the content of the books
of the you know let's maybe go down a
couple of them you know like absolutely
what were you trying to communicate well
first of all M when we started the
ogmandino Leadership Institute I hired
three people to write the curriculum MH
three of the top people at the National
Speakers Association the product didn't
sell I we think we sold $53,000 for the
product in three years and we're back in
financial challenges right and I'm a
spirit guy so I turned to the creator of
Heaven and Earth and said what's the
deal here you know I didn't go through
10 years learning how to pay off a
million dollars in debt to be back here
again right what do you want
MH Patrick it was an interesting
moment I prepared you to write
thish my response what have I got to
say three books later three assessments
two practicums I had a little bit to say
I guess yeah yeah and I think the lesson
in that is for anybody who's watching
this that sometimes because we're living
the experience we minimize the
significance of it and the power it
could have in inspiring another person
to walk a difficult Journey we minimized
the value of Our Own Story yeah I had
now it's the subject material for today
I begin a new life MH which is all about
connecting with people and using your
mind construct I ly to get inspired
ideas and living in the now in passion
driven action The Observer chair which
is all about healing self-esteem and
becoming the very best version of you an
equinity conquering Mount entrepreneur
yeah story I've been telling for years
about pulling into the parking lot I
kept saying to companies look you don't
understand your people are still in the
parking lot you're talking to them as if
they're on the path okay all you do is
this and this they're still stuck in the
car you got to get them out of the car
and get them on the path so so the book
starts in the parking lot let's get out
of the parking lot let's get into the
path and let's go up the mountain and
climb out entrepreneur so those are the
three books then the fourth one on the
way more let's talk about than T hen
more than
enough it's wanting more MH but knowing
what your enough is so that you're not
creating just for you you reach a point
where you're now creating to bless the
world so expanding that a little bit in
a nutshell yes 10% of your income goes
to a worthy cause you live on 90
yeah what you're enough as soon as I
have this stuff that's enough MH once
you're at a 9010 and your 90s enough now
you increase your income you can
increase your giving because it's been
my
experience I have an NSX and a Range
Rover and a Malibu boat and a cabin
wonderful things right but not one of
them fills the hole in my
Soul they're all there to share and
bless lives what fills the whole in my
soul is giving yeah when you have
somebody who's in a tremendous need and
you can step up and solve that issue
yeah you know yeah I do know just moves
your soul yeah you want to be in a
position to do more and more and more of
that so more than yes enough so the the
theme of this series is Is wealth
breakthrough uh so we want see people
having you know wealth breakthroughs
that they they've seem to be stuck maybe
some of them are on the part of the path
of the struggle you know where where
you've been and and I guess at this
point the struggles are a blessing right
because that's what formed your story
that allowed you to share um so in your
mind if somebody says you know I'm I I
have the at least the The Thirst the
desire to want to develop wealth and and
in many respects people will say that
it's not so much that I want so much
more for myself but I do want to be in a
position to be abundant to be able to
share to be able to give what have you
or some people might say I just want I
do want a better lifestyle I do want a
bigger house I do want a legacy for our
children whatever the motives might be
behind that what is your feeling at this
point or or your um position as far as
how people need to make a wealth
breakthrough what the elements of it are
you said the magic
word desire M but it's understanding the
word desire and how it's applied okay
because it's the fulcrum on which
everything balances mhm what is that
desire what are you wanting to
create great discovery M
1992 the educational films sto selling
yeah and that was our source of income
that was barely keeping food on the
table right and all of a sudden we're
like
destitute and I've got a million-dollar
life insurance
policy have a million dollars in debt it
doesn't take long to figure out how
those two could be related right except
for the night I planned it mhm I didn't
go through with it and the sun comes up
and I'm really
angry I long to cry to the god of my
youth MH but the god of my youth will
not Hear My Cry I must change my God or
change my
cry want to guess which one had to
change do you tell the cry yeah that's
the desire secret desire and real
intention what is it because is the
desire to engage in life to live to
embrace obstacles learn from them use
them to be more empathetic in teaching
others to connect and serve to create
value everywhere you go and with
everyone you meet and to contribute to
the world is that the burning
desire or is the secret burning desire
to have life be a little easier and less
stressful what's the desire so I get
identifying that's critical if you're
fantasizing about a Ferrari mhm nobody
need tell you the color of the car the
smell of the Interior right the road
you're driving on the fantasy unfolds
because of the
desire however if we use our mind
differently which every wealth Creator
is going to want to know how to do this
there's five ways to use it like for an
example mentally rehearsing something
right the next meeting you're going to
have the next presentation you're going
to make maybe the product you're going
to be selling you're mentally rehearsing
you're playing through it seeking for
inspired ideas intuitive Impressions
Creative Solutions that unfolds because
you have a
desire to create something to bless a
life to help a person whatever it might
be whatever that desire is to create not
to escape but a desire to create so it
really boils down to desire it boils
down to am I trying trying to escape am
I going to pretend like I care about
people until I can get a tropical island
where I can move and not have to deal
with annoying people anymore is that is
that really a desire or is my desire
really to engage and bless lives and and
leave a footprint on this planet which
one really is it right because the
evidence shows up when we get clear on
the dream mhm we get clear on where we
are current reality we look at all the
millimeters between here and there and
do we keep going to what is going to be
like when or do we focus on the next
millimeter that's the evidence of
whether that's the desire Escape or is
it create is it create so talk to me
about dreaming like uh what's the
importance of a dream or do you think
that dreaming is too uh Whimsical uh
it's got to be something more concrete
than having a dream this is my soulbox
go ahead this my so boox let's go I've
been practicing this since I was 13 okay
matter of fact last year I found the the
Honda 150 dream blue with a red seat not
the same one had 2700 miles on it for
old as it was that wasn't too bad right
but I found it and it sits in my garage
right now so every time I pull into my
garage or walked to get in my car I look
over there and it reminds me of the
principles of how to create a dream not
just have it but actually create the
dream cuz that was the first Dream I
created at 13 right was the motor
because I drive at 14 in Alabama so
that's why I created so so so when you
say you created so you dreamt of having
this particular thing I had a desire for
it yeah I also had a business I had a
paper rout
M and I'm going to Now set goals in my
paper out for getting even more
customers collecting my fees even more
effectively I'm going to accomplish this
goal because when I accomplish that goal
I will have the money to fund this dream
right so you have the dream then you
fund it by setting the goal on the
business so you take a look at it like
this I exit to share this with you you
ready y I have a life yeah of a business
right I live in my life I work on my
business too many people put their life
inside their business no offense but
it's like snorkeling and
manure got to get them separated right
you have dreams in your life you have
goals in your business okay now
requirement business needs to be a word
y income generating vehicle something
that blesses lives for good right could
be anything from chiropractor to a
filmmaker that's doing topics like this
to bless people's lives a worthy income
generating vehicle critical component of
dream creation right now in my life I'm
going to have dreams M 90day dreams
six-month dreams onee dreams and the
dream I'm ashamed to want what do you
mean by that because when I find that
one I'm going to hear the dialogue about
my worthiness and every time I do that I
discover that dialogue is showing up
right now in my dream creation and
getting in the way that's why you find
the one that's you're ashamed to want
let me give you an example yeah really
simple you take your life your business
you say okay this is very practical by
the way what's the income for the next
three months m
based on current income you don't need
to share with me but for for the for the
for the viewer just write down on a
piece of paper next three months next
three months what is your projected
income based on current activity right
okay now what would happen if we
increase that income by
10% what would that amount be so you say
I've got $10,000 a month in income that
would be $1,000 of a 10% increase right
right next month 10% another th000 next
month th000 3,000
MH now I have a budget for my first
90day Dream mhm
$3,000 what do I want to do in my life
that would be
$3,000 that would meet four tests MH
test one I can't stop thinking about it
it ignites my passion and will drive my
action two it will encourage me to
stretch and grow to become a better
person three I want to share
it both share it so people can
appreciate it also to inspire others to
do likewise and fourth to willingly
embrace the structure required to create
it that's a worthy dream but I have a
budget for it now so that's kind of cool
so for $3,000 what could fit that
category ooh I'd like to go to x right
okay you got that I turn to my business
what goals could I set what activities
could I do like calls Etc especially the
things that I've been a little reluctant
to do I've been putting those things off
I'm little uncomfortable doing that I
want the dream it's going to drive the
action so I start to look at the things
I want to do the goals I want to create
boom I create the goals accomplish that
M funds my dream now I built my business
to that level let's give it another 10%
increase now I've got like
$3,400 plus the previous three right I
got 6 $400 for the next dream what dream
you want to do for
$6,400 you do it another time now I've
got like 95 9600 for the dream you do it
another time I got like 123,000 for that
dream it drives the actions to
accomplish the goal to fund the dream
now I'm working on my business not in my
business on my business to drive it and
create the goal so it sounds like in
large part we're talking about
motivation one could say say I can I'm
setting a goal to increase 10% you know
over the next 3 months yep and uh but
that's the extent of it I have a goal to
do 10% more but there's not the dream
that's got some of the attachments to it
that you described with the four
elements that and suddenly when you do
that it it adds all this mod of force
you know behind the actions yeah because
it was just I've got a goal to increase
we're chasing money and I've never seen
the chasing of money provide the
sufficient INSP ation breathing of life
into us to actually do sustained action
over a sustained period of time so maybe
then finish the sentence so having a
wealth breakthrough is not chasing money
it is what well you chase money it
runs okay you serve people it flows yeah
that's why the worthy income generating
vehicle if it's worthy and you work on
your business which is serving people
more and more effectively the goals are
accomplished the money is generated and
it funds A Dream you've mentored a lot
of people to success you know helping
them get from where they are to where
they want to be and I'm curious as to
what's some of the experiences you've
had in that realm where you saw the
lights go on like what was it that
somebody suddenly realized that maybe
has been stuck blind spots or can't
figure out why they're stuck and
suddenly in some way that you work with
them they have their wealth breakthrough
do you have any particular examples that
you could share yes let me give you a
principle and then an example perfect
just do it like this okay this is a
shell I'm in the Shell okay I know why I
went in the Shell I'm in the Cure and
keeping of a pedophile Age 3 through
five MH this is the only safe place on
the planet right and a lot of people are
in here mhm they're in this shell and
creating this success happens out there
MH but out there there's a snowstorm and
a blizzard Subzero weather you know
we've got to go out there to make a
phone call for an example
MH and we're naked MH exposed right yeah
so we we run out there and we pick up
the phone we dial a phone number it's
like ring ring ring cortisol surge you
know ring ring ring cortisol surge
voicemail nor up anron rush we leave our
message run back in and it takes two
hours to get comfortable again to go out
and make another phone call right A lot
of people who are
pursuing wealth mhm they would love to
be
wealthy in fact live in a bit of a
cocoon if there's a breakthrough it's
recognizing am I in here MH because if
I'm in here success is going to be
created out
there and the biggest breakthrough is to
discover the dialogue I'm having about
myself is robbing me and everyone around
me of my greatest
gifts we've done assessments on
150,000 entrepreneurs well that's a lot
I've coached personally with 7,000 of
those
MH common extremely high levels of
empathy and
intuition however this dialogue talks
them out of their own
inspiration want to have a breakthrough
yes get an inspired idea and actually
act on it as if it's energ an assignment
and Discover it actually was inspired
and don't talk yourself out of
it most of them have very high levels of
practical judgment and common sense but
yet they procrastinate MH true true true
I asked them all the time uh okay so you
procrastinate what happens when you
reach a deadline and you have to jump in
and do it what do you say what do you
think they say they jump in and do it
wow that wasn't so hard wow why did I
wait so long great question yeah for the
entrepreneurs here's a breakthrough for
you MH dialogue self-sabotaging toxic
internal dialogue that's telling you you
don't have the gifting it's screaming so
loudly that it's louder than the task
task gets closer closer louder louder
louder finally louder than this we shut
it off what do we do we step into our
natural
genius and it's so incredible even we're
surprised do you think most people under
imate themselves
enormously they have no idea they've
been playing delay delay jump in
surprise for a
lifetime when they finally start living
in their
genius magic starts to happen when they
learn how to practice what we call
intrinsic validation which is stepping
into a person's world really listening
create such a safe place that their wall
can come down then their energy and
cooperation floods out ogmandino call
called it The Greatest Secret of success
in all Ventures mhm being able to create
that that moment now you've got
connection with people you're in your
Genius knowing what needs to be done and
you're using your mind to get inspired
ideas and intuitive Impressions instead
of being in fantasy or catastrophe all
the time right there's the Breakthrough
if there's anything I've done for
clients that want so badly to get there
and can't figure it out is for them to
break through in those three areas
connection with people using their mind
constructively and acting act now a says
my dreams are worthless my plans are
dust my goals are impossible scary line
huh all are of no value unless it's
followed by action action is living in
our genius he goes on to say that if I
want to remove the flutters in my heart
I act without hesitation for only action
reduces the lion of Terror to an ant of
equinity and it looks like
this all of our friends watching this
they're going to watch this they're
going to get all excited about it and
the distance between where they are and
where they want to be is going to look
like this what I do is jump okay that's
not too bad MH then the next day they go
to do it and it looks like
this so we go read another book then we
go back to reality then we go to a
seminar we go back to reality we hire a
coach go back to reality this is reality
and creation OCC occurs here yeah we
must jump without hesitation if you're
doing something worthy you'll get more
and more comfortable with the jumping
but we want to be in action you don't
get to shortcut this process well when I
feel more comfortable I'll do it you
won't feel comfortable till you do it I
want more confidence you won't have
confidence until you do it I I want to
mitigate the fear the fear won't be
relieved until you do it so those are
the three break through it's like gosh
could it be easier couldn't you give me
a pill you know a book to read or
something to watch no learn how to
connect with people and love them step
into the world and love them discipline
yourself to use your mind constructively
to get inspired ideas that ignite
passion that will drive your action
that's why the dreaming is so critical
we'll do things in our business we
haven't been doing because we have a
dream that's lighting us up we're
willing to do this to get this in your
view then what role does uh
manifestation play in all this like you
know the way that people talk about Law
of Attraction manifestation does that
factor into the Dynamics of what you're
talking about when I hear the word
manifestation of the law of attraction I
think of two things one that when we're
actually in action passion driven
because we have an inspired idea
something magical does happen people are
put on our path that we can serve and
who can serve us it speeds up Creations
to its fastest possible paac but it
doesn't just happen it is intentionally
created in terms of a law of attraction
it's a physiological reality I have
mirror neurons you have mirror neurons
overabundance of them in our amydala our
figh ORF flight center our limpic brain
now I meet
you and my mirror neurons pick up the
tone and tenor of your voice your facial
expressions from the 200 different sets
of muscles your posture sends a signal
to my brain molecules to my body those
molecules connect to the cells through
sugar fibers communicate a message it's
an energy message because the law of
attaction is energy but it's
physiological MH now I'm either feeling
drawn to or a little repelled by based
on what my mirror neurons were saying to
me MH interesting piece right yes now
imagine I walk in to talk to to you and
all the way here I've been thinking
about how could I sell them I need the
commission I want to do this I want to
close on that and then I step into the
meeting I try to act like I care about
you you probably won't be trained well
enough even an FBI profiler wouldn't be
just in all fairness yeah to pick up the
facial expressions on my face that are
leaking out because of my previous
thought process which your mirror
neurons do mhm that subtle W and they
send a signal to your brain molecules to
your body and you're feeling a little
uncomfortable with me MH and you don't
even know why because all of that
occurred before you had a conscious
thought it's that fast yeah we can't
fake it till we make it yeah so if we're
going to practice a law of attraction we
actually have to care about people
because it's discernable it's
discernable so we show up very conscious
OG mandino said it this way how will I
handle this one way silently and to
myself I'll say I love
you un wrinkle my brow bring a smile to
my lips and echo in my voice and who is
there who will not buy my goods when his
heart feels my love that was 1967 miror
neurons were discovered in
1992 well but he's really speaking
poetically to that very process of being
comfortable with a person there's a
reason for that because our thoughts do
leak out on our face and in the tone and
ton of our voice and in our posture you
can't fake your thought processes so if
we want to have a
breakthrough we actually want to start
caring about the people that's why we
when we say we're going to chase money
well and act like I care I really care
about you but I really need the money
because I want a new Porsche you know it
it doesn't work that way I actually have
to care about you work on my business
which a service service service service
service accomplish the goal I can fund
the dream and it's worthy of it yeah
because everything I did I did touched a
life for good the money is clean that's
great
money that's an interesting distinction
you it struck me he said the money's
clean it's great money what's not great
money that's a really scary topic well
we're not here to be safe well my first
go around at wealth mhm um I was still
trying to fill a hole in my soul from my
childhood and I'm not going to deal with
a list of belongings but they were
extraordinary you know you go Ferrari
ski lodges beautiful home full-time
housekeeper Gardener 40ft custom
Bluebird home I could go through all
that kind of stuff and just say yeah
Rolex watches mhm nothing filled the
hole in my soul MH I still remember
driving off of Mount Helix coming to a
stop sign and going oh my goodness I
didn't put on my
Rolex now what do I do do I continue and
be on time for the meeting do I go home
and get my watch what do you think I did
you went home and got your watch I went
home and got my watch cuz I was my watch
the money I was earning was to try to
fill the hole in my soul is that dirty
as in like Mafia dirty no but it wasn't
for a worthy purpose now look got nice
things but if I had to sell them all it
was I'm not attached to them you want to
be careful in the process of wealth
creation we understand what real wealth
is cuz I'll share with you the
Breakthrough go ahead case in point
happens to me all the time client calls
me last December they went from a couple
hundred, a year to
$750,000 a year mhm pretty good growth
for a couple years right right they
committed to put 10% of that aside to
give to worthy causes they lived on the
difference it funded everything from
retirement everything everything on
they're living on the T their children
are in a Christmas play at the community
theater so they go to watch obviously
during the intermission they're talking
to the folks around there in the
audience and discovered didn't know this
this community theater invites all the
children from that Community to
participate ones in wheelchairs autistic
children learning disabilities they all
have something to do to make that
Christmas play
happen she was so emotionally moved by
that she turned to her husband as they
sat back down and said how much is left
in our giving fund and he said
$10,000 he knew exactly where she was
headed he said I agree MH the next day
they call this director mhm we were at
the play last
night and we learned something about
your theater and we were so impressed
we've made a decision we're sending you
a check for
$10,000 now there sharing this with me
privately I'm not mentioning any names
to keep it that way and they weren't
doing it to brag they were doing it to
share with me because it was such a
tender moment right they said this woman
broke into tears and was balling and
finally all she could say was you have
no
idea you have no
idea she said it's the most important
thing we've ever done in our lives wow
what do you think they're doing this
Christ
Christmas you give more yeah and they've
up the percentage well that's how you
want to live it's a neighbor I talked to
his personal assistant he says I have to
tell you
something Jason called me and said I
want you to buy this number of pairs of
boots and meet me down at Pioneer Park
that's where the homeless people in Salt
Lake live and they get down there and
Isis okay uh these are size 10 those go
to Bill these are eights those are
Mary's M this neighbor I won't I won't
mention the company I bet he sold her
for hundreds of millions of
dollars and he's buying boots for the
homeless people in Pioneer
Park one of many many many things he
does in the year one of the most
gracious giving kind
people that's when it gets joyful now he
lives in a 50,000 square foot home
indoor pool outdoor pool Vineyard bought
the culd AAC and put up a gate I mean
it's 100 acres yeah he is one of the
most amazing human beings I have ever
met but to use your term from earlier uh
he's not his Rolex yeah he's not his
stuff
yeah does you can't have stuff he has
great stuff
yeah he owns a a diving company in
Hawaii for for having seak I me he's
he's very very wealthy but if you spent
time with him just out in public you
would never know it he's just so
friendly and kind and outgoing and
helpful and committed to changing the
world yeah I'll tell you one more go
ahead I'm with a a friend down in San
Diego he just sold this company Net at
$110 million not bad right not bad it's
okay everybody says wow I could go get
this this and this and I asked him I
said what are you doing with the money I
was close enough to ask him that yeah he
said well I took $10 million and put
away in Investments mhm because at a 5%
return that will replace my salary from
the
business okay MH what are you doing with
the other 100 million said I'm going to
change the world now I know since then
to now that's all he's been doing is
changing the world his enough was $10
million because it produced the income
he said I still answer the door for the
pizza guy I still do the dishes with my
wife now he says I have bought a couple
nicer suits
but there's nothing in his life that
changed because he already had enough he
was already a successful executive at
the company that was sold he wasn't
waiting to get rich to go travel the
world and have you ever heard those
people say if oh I just love the travel
the beaches of the world yeah you do
that for like two or three weeks and
it's like now what yeah like I'm bored
you know let's let's let's go do
something good let's go create something
so there's these two profiles really and
maybe you can
describe not the difference on the
surface but the difference of what's
underneath where you have the person
like you just described you know wealthy
you know cashes out for large sums of
money and and they have such a sense of
fulfillment that's now how can I use my
fortune which almost do s like they
would even say my fortune but this
Fortune to go change something in the
world and and and make an impact in that
way and if you look at the wealthiest
people you look at you know Gates and
the Gates Foundation and Buffett putting
his fortune in ETC you know this is it
seems to be that that genre if you will
of of super wealthy
people then you have another genre of
people who actually did create you know
big wealth MH but they still feel it
seem like they're feeling a hole they're
buying bigger and bigger Yachts they're
you know going through you know divorce
after divorce they're you know they're
you know somehow still can't get to a
point where they have the gift of
fulfillment in their life isn't it
tragic it's tragic so where did they go
wrong they're able to create the wealth
I mean you know in a material sense they
did they did it and yet it's
still to them on that personal level
doesn't make them happy having been
there m smaller scale but having having
been there with several million dollars
mhm I know why I had the hole and it's
not unusual that something like that
created it MH so I can't have any
judgment for someone who's trying to buy
stuff to fill a hole you just want to
give them a big hug tell them it's okay
and and you're going to pursue that till
you die and when you die on your
deathbed is like I still feel this
emptiness the difference in the first
category they're not doing this for
fulfillment they were already fulfilled
MH they see this as a stewardship
responsibility I'm a steward over these
funds I have all my needs met now what
can I do to change this world it's just
a different view it's no longer about
them that's a beautiful place that just
takes healing yeah and some people have
been able to create wealth without ever
healing and that's really sad so the
still had the attributes of being able
to generate and create wealth they had
those attributes uh so there's some
there's some virtues there but
unfortunately there's also a hole that
uh debilitates they have wealth but
they're not wealthy yeah so given that
distinction how would you describe being
wealthy reason for the book more than
enough mhm I think we're supposed to
want more our clay mhm we have a
tendency to want someone else's clay
their life their body their hair their
car their house we take our clay our
current
circumstances and I think this is
important for your listeners because
some people don't like their clay you
don't understand Dave I don't like this
I got this happening this happening this
happening go well but that's your clay
and it's given to us uniquely to prepare
us for our life so we choose our clay I
choose my clay my circumstances now I
begin the process process of creating
the most I can with what I have but if I
had 10 million I don't have $10 million
so that's not an option what do I have
what can I create with what I have
because once we start to magnify the
clay we've been
given here's a principle we're giv more
clay there's not a power in the universe
that'll give you more of something you
don't
want we're supposed to want more of our
clay so we start building more and more
and more we're given more and more clay
it's so essential in this build that we
Define what is our
enough if we know that going into the
build it's not in concrete but having an
idea that's a big enough house that's a
nice enough car MH um that's good enough
vacations this is enough for retirement
once we know our enough then we can
begin the process of giving more than
the 10% M the 10's critical from the
beginning CU if if we don't give 10 from
the beginning we'll never give CU we'll
never have enough to give right so we
want to be giving that 10 because there
is fulfillment in that 10 it just gets
sweeter with
more so we build more to
enough put more in the giving pile and
we can have even greater levels of joy
in our giving but we're already
fulfilled that's the secret we're
already fulfilled if we're looking for
wealth to solve our feelings about
ourselves so we'll be happy mhm it'll
never make us happy yeah I've heard uh
money is just an amplifier so whatever
you got it's going to
amplify if you're a troubled person
you're going to be even more troubled if
you're a good person you're going to be
an even better person absolutely yeah
well so looking at uh this I guess I'll
call it this phase of of your life you
know with the new book in these themes
that you're you're sharing with the
world MH how are you feeling about thing
I mean there's more wealth in the world
than ever looks like it's going to
increase and accelerate do you feel like
we're moving in a good
direction that is really a loaded
question love
capitalism so I love competition I think
we ought to put it into the Health Care
System a little bit more effectively
that would help us yeah I even got ideas
around that not a bad idea right I'm a
little concerned the some of the wealth
accumulation has a has a few too many
people trying to fill a hole in their
soul m a little concerned about that MH
uh for those who are getting ready to
build I I would say I'm most excited for
them because if they could build
differently yeah they could be fulfilled
in the journey joy in the Journey of
building right because the joy is in the
creation of the dream it's not the
destination we ought to go off on that
for a minute because please intentional
creators create through dreams here's
the dream they create through they're on
the next one the next one the next one
and when they're done doing their own
they start doing it for others right so
they fall in love with the very process
of getting an inspired idea taking on a
challenge correcting it building
something that wasn't there before they
loved the process of creation too many
of the other people were talking about
are destination driven when I get to
this point but that's never enough when
I get to this point we're always waiting
to be happy when we get somewhere to
this new generation that we're talking
to okay you want a
breakthrough let's have some
foundational principles in place let's
love people let's use our mind
constructively let's live present and
the Now using our natural genius and
let's take the clay we've been given and
let's create as much as we can let's not
be in comparative reality we're not in
competition with anyone we're becoming
the best version of ourself right yes
and we're using our funds 10% of it to
serve and when we have enough to meet
our needs with the 90 we give
more and I think it's it's something
that can't be
compulsory no now this is going to be
revelatory I don't think you can tax it
out of
me I'll give you an example you say well
the wealthy need to be taxed more you
can take all their incentive away for
doing it in the first place that's right
that doesn't work they they stop doing
it so we don't want to be in that
position that's like those who want to
build wealth who've got Debt M so well
first I got to pay off my Deb MH for
everybody watching this that wants to be
involved in wealth ation who's got debt
don't focus on paying off your debt
focus on creating something you don't
have and have some Joy from it a little
bit more and a little bit more you'll
get your debt paid off yeah but if your
focus is debt getting out of that hole
back to even is not a motivation for
creation back to your own personal story
you had a million dollars in debt and uh
you went off and did something very
creative and very new that you seem to
enjoy which got the debt paid the debt
got paid and I had a blast making films
as compared to feeling like you're
slaving away way and lamenting about how
the world's not fair Patrick I was
working 16-hour days and no exaggeration
almost 6 days a week and for almost 10
years yeah and there is no exaggeration
because I was writing a film editing a
film and shooting a film all at the same
time you got to do 200 of them over that
period of time that's really complex
work yeah why would you work like that I
remember Bill Bennett's Book of Virtues
I wrote and directed The infomercial for
PBS
and I kept telling the New York
producers let's not shoot this stuff up
at the lake with the great big lights
and imitating the sun let's go shoot the
testimonials first because they're going
to tell us so much then let's ride
around the testimonials they made us
shoot that first so we shot it first MH
then we went and shot the
testimonials not one not one foot of
that footage shot up at the lake made it
into the infomercial m but here's what
happened it got delayed so far and PBS
has got a drop dead date mhm which means
I had to edit for 36 hours that's three
editors 12 hours a piece MH I slept for
an hour and a half got a shower did it
for another
36 slept and took a shower and did it
for another 36 well I still haven't
recovered I but how can you do that if
it's just boring mundane competitive
burdensome work mhm it was my baby it
was my
vision my passion was ignited I was
executing on passion we wanted this
thing to be perfect yeah that's what the
dream creates I think implied in a lot
of what you're saying and tell me if
this is accurate but you you have a
premise that everybody has an inherent
genius it's not just some lucky few I
don't think we've done an assessment yet
where we didn't have natural genius we
just have a proclivity a natural
negative tendency to look at what's
wrong well we'll want to see what's
wrong because it's probably a lot of
noise keeping us from accessing our
genius but I want to get people in their
genius because once they start playing
around with that they start to find out
who they really are and when they find
out who they really are there's a peace
that can come to them a fulfillment that
could start to come to them and they
start to get excited about getting an
inspired idea acting on it as if it's an
urgent assignment proving that it
actually was inspired feeling like
they're in partnership with the universe
and the creation of whatever they're
doing you can hardly sleep at night and
that's safe to say discovering your own
genius is a critical aspect of having a
wealth breakthrough well I'll give you
the objective okay and I'm going to
quote Dr Robert Hartman from the Hartman
Institute the objective is to be
real genuine and authentic without the
need to impress pretend feel ashamed or
fear MH that's the most difficult task
on our mortal existence and the highest
level of maturity well repeat it again
then to be real genuine and authentic
real means to develop relationships with
people genuine root word
genus
genius the re word of Genius is
genius it's to
fully embrace your natural genius and
bring it to the service of another
person you don't Embrace genius as say
look how brilliant I am no you shut off
the noise so you can bring it and serve
totally available can you imagine what
you could do living in your Genius in
the service of another person and
working on your business business and
creating those goals right so we live in
our genius being genuine authentic anthc
are true self
the noise that self-sabotaging dialogue
that if I said half the things to you
that you say to yourself could we still
be friends that dialogue right that's
not our true self it might be our
dominant voice but it's not our true
self that's where we get in our genius
so we could start to hear our true voice
our real self then we can be real
because we'll start creating
relationships we're comfortable too mhm
we'll be genuine we'll jump in we'll get
the task done bring our genius and we'll
be authentic anthc our true selves yeah
can you feel the peace from that no need
to impress pretend feel ashamed or fear
most difficult task in our mortal
existence and the highest level of
maturity funny story I'm a car guy okay
I'm a car guy 2004 I've got a red NSX
with a with a tan interior '96 I got a
97 now but I had a 96 then I'm driving
driving down the street and these two
16-year-old guys go and I'm
going do I really want to be driving a
car the 16-year-old guys
go and I thought am I becoming my stuff
again yeah don't know mhm let's find out
we had these two buildings downtown they
were historical buildings and one of
them had a garage in the back so I
parked the car in the garage and covered
it locked the garage and left it there
for 9 months
well and intentionally drove a Honda
Civic with a cracked
windshield I just want to see if I could
uhuh I could that's fine when I got the
car out the battery was dead that caused
all kinds of problems CU all the
emission sensors were dead too and and
it was hard to get a mission test pass
Etc anyway bottom line was are we our
stuff are we trying to find happiness
elsewhere or are we focusing on just
being real the
objective real genuine authentic without
the need to
impress which is to try to make a big
deal of what we have pretend act like we
have something we don't have feel shame
a sham that covering have that wet
blanket over the flame that burns inside
of us or fear to experience fear false
evidence appearing real are we going to
let fear crush us let's just be real
genuine and
authentic then we start creating wealth
then we can use that money to create
wonderful things for our family I got a
neighbor takes 42 family members on a
twoe first class vacation every year you
could put the bath to that right yeah
that's part of his enough some people
might say well why doesn't he give that
to an
orphanage if you saw his kids and his
grandkids and what he's created in that
family every penny is worth it's
incredible what he's created right
amazing human being an amazing family
yeah that's so great can you remember
the first dream that you created oh yeah
now a couple years ago my father passed
away and I woke up at 2:00 in the
morning and I was missing him and I had
this impression to go look on ksl.com
it's the local online classified ads so
I went in the bathroom didn't want to
wake up my wife and I plug it
in and the very first thing that pops up
is a
1966 Honda dream blue with a red
seat that's a that's a motorcycle like a
small like a mini bike basically it's a
big a motorcycle 150 CC's sure here's
the dream I'm 13 I'm almost ready to
turn 14 in Alabama you can drive a
motorcycle at 14 I've got a paper route
and it's really difficult to deliver the
number of papers I'm taking on on a
bicycle on Sunday my mother's driving us
around the Volkswagen and Bug imagine
the top back I'm standing up delivering
the papers like this and she wanted to
have the freedom on Sunday morning
because that was like a 5:00 in the
morning thing so I have this worthy
dream to create this motorcycle it's 280
bucks MH my father said if you'll pay
for half of it I'll pay the other half
so I need to raise $140 so I'm boy am I
collecting and I'm I'm getting new
customers and I'm driving that business
to get that $140 and I got it now my
father finds the motorcycle my favorite
memory of my dad is him driving down the
street and pulling into my driveway with
that
motorcycle it's interesting that that
was the motorcycle for sale on the
newspaper at ksl.com so I I look all
night for for a picture of me at 14
sitting on this motorcycle I find it I
send it to the guy and say I want this
I'll pay you this much and he said wrote
back not only is it yours I'll deliver
it to you so I have sitting in my garage
a 1966 Honda 150 dream blew with a red
seat with
272 mil on it that sits there I don't
drive it very often but it's a reminder
every morning when I go out to my car
and every night when I pull into that
bay mhm of why I believe in dreaming
that was the first one I remembered wow
dream
execute accomplish
fund
lifetime you mentioned five ways to use
your mind and and I think you gave us
one but uh what are the other four well
there are seven ways five constructive
two destructive okay now 97% of people
who are pursuing wealth have the gift to
vividly
visualize 98% of those it's pretty
significant use it destructively to
catastrophize play out worst case
scenarios or to escape to the Future to
Anze 98% 2% use it constructively I'd
like to switch that by showing people
how to use it to get an inspired idea if
there's anyone I can serve put them on
my path and I'll serve them to mentally
rehearse the next event and get an
inspired idea to explore possibilities
without making tangible commitments to
problem solve to plan to goal set to
identify those dreams when our mind is
in that space what can I create how can
I create that how will I serve that is
all always answered with an inspired
idea that's what's manifest using Vivid
visualization it's not the actual
tangible thing it's the idea that
ignites the passion to drive the work to
create the tangible
thing so then if we ever to list these
so basically uh to go down the list of
the five saying how to use your mind and
actually you know it's really
interesting that you say it's not
there's five constructive ways and two
destructive ways yeah how many people
are uh you are running the destructive
modes 98% of people with the gift of
vivid visualization which is 97% of
everybody wanting to create wealth
really it's huge and what happens is we
go into fantasy then life shows up
differently and we have this
overwhelming physiological
reaction and then we start hating our
life because there's nothing about our
life that showing up the way we would
like it to then we start beating
ourselves up and we start to question
our worth and our worthiness and our
ability and our beliefs and our
character and the value of our
contribution this sequence is killing
people and frankly the world far too
often wants us to believe that if we
visualize with enough intention there's
a fantasy fairy that's going to somehow
magically manifested and so people keep
going down that road believing that
there's just something they're missing
they must not be doing it with enough
intention it's a wrong road it's a wrong
road you can't create wealth in fantasy
you get an inspired idea that ignites
your passion you do the work you'll
create right that's how you create a
dream interesting yeah cuz there's there
is a a lot of people say you know that
believe in the fantasy fairy I guess is
the way that you put it right
millionaire magic
Doctrine interesting and certainly hope
somebody nobody blows up my house house
home after saying
that yeah and it's not necessarily
categorically wrong it's incomplete is I
think what you're saying right I mean
having um you know a dream MH but then I
can remember a long time reading an
article saying that you have to also
become a Dream Merchant you can't just
have the dream but you have to take some
action action so that's a fascinating
view of it and uh and and I think
probably one of the most important
elements as as you're describing it is
the is that you have the motivation
and that drives the work so that you
have you know you have the the fuel to
be able to go out and create because it
takes energy let's distinguish
between I'd like to have versus I want
to
create great distinction yeah yeah I
want that I want that to happen mhm what
doesn't
happen it gets intentionally created mhm
yeah if we get that distinction down
clear we're going to have a whole lot
less pain and suffering in the wealth
creation process CU too too many people
want it manifest so many people want it
to
disappear doesn't work that way I could
scream about this because there are just
too many people who have pursued that
easy path that easy button mhm and to a
person they're broke broken and angry
interesting I've taken Tak this on as a
mission not to make the person wrong
who's teaching manifestation to help the
person who wants to create a dream
actually create
it I don't want to speak disparagingly
about someone who might teach something
that's driving people into fantasy I
just know we need to have a louder voice
out there to show people how to actually
create a dream so it's not about
dreaming it's about creating a
dream I recently wrote a song with Randy
Kartchner
matter of fact I I'll get a a copy of it
maybe you can share it with the program
but it goes like this deep in our dreams
where the whispers are real words softly
spoken voices we
feel calling us higher than we've ever
flown giving us Wings to a world yet
unknown dream come with me and dream
putting all the fears behind you the
tears the that blind you the chains that
make you
scream just
dream the burdens of Life kill our
purpose and peace broken and angry we
cry for relief but dreaming inspires us
to reach for the stars healing our
wounds and removing the
scars dream come with me and dream
putting all the fears behind you the
tears that blind you the chains that
make you scream come with me and dream
putting all the tragedy behind you
letting hope and joy remind you to
become the one that finds you when you
dream remember all the pain and fear
that has crushed your life and stole
your dreams for years reach deep down
inside your soul feel the flame that
burns declare the truth you
know stream come with me and
dream putting all the fears behind you
the tears that blind you the chains that
make you scream
dream come with me and
dream putting all the tragedy behind you
letting hope and joy remind you to
become the one who finds you when you
dream now someone might say are you
selling fantasy
no we've got a lot of people in society
so beat down by life circumstances they
don't dare dream because when they have
in a Fantastical way they just got hurt
our invitation is come and dream then
let us show you how to actually build a
foundation underneath that David th said
that if you've got Castles in the Sky
that's okay keep them there now build a
foundation underneath them have a dream
a worthy dream now have a worthy income
generating vehicle and do the work of
working on it serving the people and
create the revenue and fund the Dream
well on that note s uh a note of uh with
a beautiful tone tone so thank you for
sharing that uh I just want to say that
I very much appreciate you your spirit
your purpose and the fact that you took
your time to sit here and share this
with our audience so thank you so much
you're welcome it's been privilege to
see the next episode in the wealth
breakthrough series check the video
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there there's a difference between
an investor and a Trader right an
investor you have a much different time
Horizon on your hand you have a much
different plan they can't pay attention
to what the trader wants to do what the
algorithms are doing they have to say
look here's my goal